Everybody, hello, hello.
I'm sorry for being late.
I had to teach my child how to use VTube Studios.
So apparently, TvDoki has never used the collab feature during, um, ever.
So she was like, I've been just screen sharing my, my model for the other.
Who are the other VTubers?
And I was like, what?
So I was giving, I was like, no, no, I'm not in a call yet.
I'm not in a call yet.
I'm roasting her a little bit before I call her.
Uh, don't worry, I'll roast her, I'll roast her in the call too.
But I just need to explain why I am a little late.
But basically, she's never used VTube Studios collab feature before.
So I was giving her like a step-by-step guide.
Uh, yeah, I revoked her speaking rights though.
Don't talk to me or my child again.
So I was giving her a step-by-step guide on how to like turn it on and, um, and everything.
So I'm taking my child to the beach.
Alright, I'm gonna call it, I'm gonna call it, uh, Chibi real quick.
Uh, alright, uh, sound guy, I hope you're ready because I...
I hope you're ready.
Uh, cause we definitely need to balance this.
Okay.
Hello!
Oh, wow, wow.
Hello, Chibi!
Hello, hello!
I heard you were roasting me on your stream.
Oh, I mean, you roasted yourself plenty enough.
Listen, listen, listen, I figured that out.
It took way longer than it should've, but I didn't.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, can I, alright, let me, can I read your chat message, what you said?
I...
Oh, how do I do that?
I was like, okay, so, alright, what's your Steam ID so we can set up a collab room?
What is a collab room?
Dude, that's, like, self-reporting, I get no YouTube review words, bro.
I'm not collaborating with anyone.
I was like, I was like, Chibi, it's been out, it's been a feature for at least a year now.
All those friends are 36-year-old men with dongs.
Like, I don't like...
Don't tell the cops that.
Don't...
Alright, hello everybody, this is Chibi Doki, and I am regular size Doki.
We're just the Doki Doki alliance.
Yeah, we're the Doki squared.
Uh, when people will be like, I like Chibi Doki, they're like, which one?
I know, do you have a big head toggle?
I can't turn that off.
Oh, wait, that's a big head?
I thought that was your regular size head.
No, no!
Hold up, wait, turn off.
This is my... Oh, I could do that too, wait.
Wait, can you really?
Yeah, I could do that too, give me a sec, I need to plug something in my...
Sorry, I need to plug my extender.
Just eat a pencil, that's what does it for me.
Don't talk to me or my child again.
She's born!
Alright, don't worry, watch this.
There you go.
She ate a Prinkles can!
I'm taking my daughter to the beach right now, guys.
Yeah, guys, guess where I get my next one.
She has a little floaty or she'll die.
Without the floaty, she literally sinks down.
She's like a fucking giant ass rock, so she'll sink down the ocean.
My head is just a ball of lead.
Yeah, so you put this child into the ocean, she'll fall straight into the... straight to the bottom.
Why are you gonna pump me?
You're also very puntable, so be careful.
Yeah, yeah, kick the baby.
Kick the baby.
Plan C, motherfucker.
But yeah, you can see the family resemblance, right?
I was so excited, because when you DM'd me, you're like, hey, do you want to play something?
You're like so good at games.
I was like, oh no, she's going to want to play like Apex or this game.
Don't worry, no, I will not drag you to hell.
Yeah, so I was like, alright, so we have...
I gave her like a list of games.
I was like, there's a Roblox doors.
Look at you, look at you!
What do you mean as a two-year-old?
Look at you!
You have a fucking rubber ducky floaty!
No!
That was your choice!
What do you mean?
Listen, you're telling me, you're telling me, you would not pick a rubber ducky floaty.
That's freaking lit!
Like, this is awesome!
We have the same theme!
You see a rubber ducky floaty right now?
Oh, wait, I forgot I can grab you.
This is awesome, dude.
You know, I was like, Chewie, you know you could like...
I shouldn't have taught you how to move ourselves.
Oh my god, Doki, stop!
Stop!
What are you doing?
Stop it!
Now you have too much power.
I know.
I'll give the people what they want.
What are you giving?
We're just in a lot of toes.
Rent is new Doki at the last.
Yeah, that's why she started collabing with YouTubers again.
The 40-year-old men weren't doing it for her.
So she had to come back crawling.
Yeah, I hope.
I know.
To what's worth coming, dude.
Oh my gosh.
You're like, please welcome me back.
I'm sorry.
Give me back!
Please!
Alright, let me set up the Roblox doors game real quick.
I've never beaten doors, have you?
Never beaten doors?
Wait, have you not done chapter one at least?
I've never beaten it, no.
Not even chapter one?
Well, the thing is, like, it's really, really sad because I streamed doors with my best friend Nags.
Yeah.
And then we, like, got to room 90 and died.
And I was like, I can beat this.
So I played it off stream, like, five times and lost every single time.
Alright, but did you pay to win?
Oh my god, wait, hello?
Hello?
Oh, sorry, I think you got taken for a second.
Oh, what?
They got you.
They got me.
They're like, she knows too much.
She taught Chibi how to, how to use VTube Studios.
I have so much power.
Dude, I'm gonna collab with so many VTubers now.
Just for the fact that I can grab them and, like, ragdoll them.
You're just like, I didn't want to screen share, so I said no.
Although, now I can, like, grab my waifus and throw them at the wall.
It's awesome.
That was my breaking point screen sharing.
Dude, I feel so smart.
Like, this is so cool.
Whoa.
This is so awesome, dude.
Alright, we're going to the beach now.
Oh, we should have played a beach game.
A beach game?
Oh, like, yeah.
Alright, let me...
Go fishing.
That's not the beach.
I've been fishing at the beach.
You've been fishing at the beach?
Yeah.
Did he let you do that?
Wait, no, actually, that's a lie.
Is that illegal?
Yeah, I was going to say, isn't that illegal?
Yeah, I'm not going to lie for attention.
I caught a catfish.
Oh, shit.
Yeah.
Did you eat it?
No, I actually chucked it back in.
You chucked it?
Oh, my God.
So, you basically tortured the fish by bringing it out of...
I gave it a cannon event for it to, like, you know, like, help his family.
You're like, I'm going to, you're like, change the trajectory of his life forever.
You killed his friends.
When I see a happy couple, I walk up through them and start ripping my eyes out.
You catch him and then killed, like, a bunch of his friends in front of him and then let him back into the ocean.
No one will believe you.
Your life won't change forever.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
How the fuck...
Where do you...
Doors.
Where the fuck is this game?
I don't want to add people.
Add friends.
Oh, God.
Uh, no, I already got...
I already added you.
Is your name DokiBird69?
No!
That's not me!
I did not!
What the fuck is that?
That is not me.
Their name is DokiBird69.
They didn't just add all the Doki's.
Like, you don't know...
Wait, are you Doki...
Are you DokiFPS?
Do you keep your wife?
That's me.
You like my face?
I like how your avatar is just you.
Dude, look at my...
Look at my avatar.
You're...
Are you giving back shots?
The frickin'...
What's your name?
You're talking to take it?
Yeah, you're...
Dude, what the frick?
You're the caboose if you know what I'm saying.
Oh, yeah.
I'm here to give all...
Give all the trains some back shots.
There's people that are into that.
They just wanna fuck trains.
And...
Dragons wanna do cars.
Yeah.
What?
Have you seen that subreddit?
Oh!
Wait!
What?
I'm one of the founding fathers.
There's like a subreddit about dragons humping cars.
And that's some people's thing.
And I'm like...
Oh, there's a thing about where like...
There's like transformation where they...
People transforms into planes.
Have you seen that?
No, but I've seen one where they animorph into a diaper and then cry.
Okay, but like...
That's like...
What?
That's common?
There's like people who are like...
Just obsessed with...
Um...
Just obsessed with like...
Diapers in general.
Are you speaking from experience?
No, I just...
I've been on the internet for too long.
Wait, Astrid...
Wait, look at this.
Show this to your stream.
Cause I can't do it on YouTube.
I...
Oh my...
Dude!
It's gaping!
Guys, I can't show this on YouTube.
Oh, I'll take a 3...
I'll take a 3D band.
Wait, can you see this one on YouTube studio?
No, no, no.
Okay, cool.
No, wait, I can!
Wait, I can!
It like popped up!
It's okay.
It was only there for 0.1 second.
I'm okay.
It's like the 5 second rule.
Listen.
There's nothing inherently sexual about this.
If you get a fan...
Yeah.
That's the reporter self-reporting.
They got hard.
So like that's...
That's their problem.
It's the moderators being like...
It's them.
Look how my sound guy was like, Okay, let's bring down Chimidoki just a little bit.
You have a sound guy.
I have a sound guy.
I was telling my chat that like I'm...
Like you are so professional.
And I'm like a freaking straight cat.
I was like, Dude!
Dude, I don't even know what the freaking collab room is!
I'm a sound guy!
Okay, yeah.
Do you have a boom mic?
Oh god, no.
I do have...
My mic is a thousand dollars.
I know.
Don't worry, Chibi.
I can tell.
Don't worry.
At that point, it's your brand.
You know?
It's your...
That's your...
It's my thing!
It's your thing, you know?
Yeah!
Definitely!
Look, people enjoy when you peak your mic, you know?
Like, if you get a thousand dollar mic, you can't do that anymore.
Actually, no.
You can.
It like picks it up even better.
Okay.
Well, the worst thing is, like, three years ago, I bought a really expensive microphone.
And it's still in the box.
What?
Because...
Okay, the reason why is because this one...
This mic is a USB microphone, and I thought all microphones were USB.
Uh-huh.
This one has a different, like, doohickey at the end, but I don't know what...
Yeah, like an actual microphone.
I don't know what it is, so I never used it.
It's like...
Okay, wait, do you have a mixer?
What?
Wait, wait, I'm curious.
How long...
How long have you been streaming, Chibi?
Wait...
You're saving money.
That's good.
You're saving...
You're saving money, Chibi.
Don't...
Don't worry.
You're just a little kid.
You're just a little guy.
You're...
Stop!
It's like...
You give, like, your chat the...
I can take care of her experience, you know?
That's...
Well...
I don't know...
I don't know about that.
I don't know, dude.
I like...
Dude, my audience, bro, they're worse than me.
Like, you don't even know.
Oh, so...
They're basically at...
They've, like, agreed that they can't fix you anymore.
I...
So they're like, I can't fix her.
But...
Listen...
People like bad girls, and I'm bad at everything.
I don't think that...
I don't...
I don't think you know what that means.
I...
What?
I don't think...
Man, I ulted.
I thought that was, like, a really good thing to say.
I don't think...
I think...
Eat a pencil.
It's like those things parents tell you, where you're like...
Uh...
Where you're like, don't worry, your dog went to a farm downstate.
And...
What?
Wait...
I actually had a family dog.
Go...
Dude...
Oh...
Don't worry, he's still there.
He's living his best life at that farm, you know?
Really?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
He's, like...
He's, like, playing with all the squirrels he wants to play with at that farm.
Oh my god!
Yeah!
That's so awesome!
Yeah, yeah.
It's been, like, how many years?
20 years since he's been in that farm?
Yeah!
Don't worry.
He's still...
Yeah, dogs can live, like, 40 years.
I don't know if you know that.
Jesus!
He should run for Senate.
Yeah!
I should go...
I should be a lawyer.
No!
Alright, wait.
Did you add me yet?
Wait, I think I did.
Okay, just join my lobby.
Add friends.
Did I add you?
Yes, I did.
I'll also add DokiBird69.
Yeah, just add him for two.
Maybe he can join us.
Maybe we can beat doors with DokiBird69.
He could carry us.
Yeah!
Alright.
Do you see...
Game Capture?
Alright, I should Game Capture, too.
Alright, Sound Guy.
Let me know if the game volume's okay.
This is also why I was Sound Guy, too.
I love that their name is just Sound Guy.
Yeah!
What?
Sound Guy.
That's so freaking funny.
Alright.
Boom.
Alright, I'm almost ready.
Sorry, it's my first day.
Yeah, first day of the...
Year four.
Oh, I get the grab Doki.
Get in the frickin'.
Yeah!
Oh, I forgot.
Roblox, you have to do, like...
Window Capture.
Yeah, yeah.
I forgot, too.
Yeah, I was like, where the fuck are you?
Okay, they...
Wait, where are you?
Oh, they're...
I have scoliosis!
What the frick?
You ate the list from the frickin'.
Look at her.
She has scoliosis.
It's in condition!
Look at her.
She has scurriosis.
Look at that.
Dude, your balls deep in fr... What's his name?
What's his name?
The tank guy?
Thomas the Tank Engine.
You should know him.
That's like a show geared towards your age group.
Okay, how old are you?
Grandma!
Yeah?
I don't have to be older than you.
I just gotta be taller.
I think you're like 32.
Bro, what?
I bet you're like 36.
This is the girl that hangs out with 40 year olds.
They're my babysitters!
My mom pays them to be my friend.
Aww, that's okay.
She paid me too.
Let's get into this room.
Come on, child.
Let's get in here.
Hey!
Let me out!
Let's go.
Did you have that like dilemma when you first started streaming that you thought like your parents like paid bots to watch you?
Oh, yeah.
I did at first.
I did at first, yeah.
Alright, I don't need any of this.
I'm not spending my Robux yet.
Oh my god!
You hit puberty!
Holy shit!
Hey, what's up?
Whoa!
Do I stop Thomas?
Oh, I don't have Thomas anymore.
Wait, dude.
We were Eiffel... nevermind.
No, we were Eiffel Tower, Thomas.
Do you want... Okay, you can have his...
Oh my god, he's got a hole in the back!
His face is... I don't want...
He's got a hole in the back!
Okay, let me... Okay, Sound Guy said, Before she starts screaming, let's turn her down a little bit!
Hi, Sound Guy!
Oh my god.
Whoa, what is... Wait, is that actually part of your... your outfit?
What are you looking at?
What are you doing?
I'm looking at the... the heart... the heart hole next to your crouch.
What the... what... what are you looking at?
Oh god, I'm getting insecure.
It's literally... it's literally positioned in your crouch area.
Listen, what does this do?
We gotta get the key.
Yeah, yeah, okay.
Wait, I need to change the settings for this.
Alright, where is the...
I don't like the...
Are you... are you Eiffel Towering Thomas right now?
You... you want... you really want his face?
Actually, no, I feel like he's a biter.
He looks like a biter.
Okay.
Dude, his bump is so big.
Yeah?
Whoa, let's back it up.
Open the fucking door, child.
Okay, okay.
Alright, let's go.
Alright.
Oh, look at all the closets.
Alright, let's go.
We can't go in the closet yet.
We're only at room three.
Oh.
Alright.
Three?
Okay, oh yeah, I forgot you can open these.
Oh, there's money.
Yeah, yeah.
We can actually buy stuff.
I forgot how to play this game, by the way.
Do you... do you remember how...
When was the last time you played doors?
What was that?
You bitch.
It's like I messed up.
God, I see your donkey before I see you.
Oh, it was rain.
Okay, nice.
I got the money.
Alright, so when was the last time you played doors, GB?
Uh...
Maybe like...
Couple months ago, I think.
Okay, that's good.
So we were both going in with zero knowledge.
Yeah.
I played...
There's like...
Twitch crowd control.
Uh...
Wait, for Roblox?
For doors?
Yeah, for doors.
Yeah, yeah.
How do they control it?
They type in chat and they vote what happens to you.
And uh...
It's really bad.
Yeah, you're never beating this game.
I was gonna say, you're never beating this game.
They pelt you with tomatoes.
It's bad.
It's really bad.
Don't worry, I believe.
Oh!
Wait, I heard you got something.
What is that?
I found a battery.
I'mma lick it.
I don't know what that does.
Have you ever actually licked a battery before?
No, but when I was a kid and often times an adult, I would plug it...
With your iPhone charger?
What do you mean often times?
Occasionally, I would...
You plug in your iPhone charger and you know like the little part you put in the phone, I'd lick it and it'd be spicy.
It's like a little sour and it like zaps you a little.
Yeah, and you'll never have to grow up after that.
Mentally, you'll always be there.
And life got good after that.
I found a key.
Oh nice, that's what we need.
Don't worry, I have money.
I also, as a kid, had a salt lamp, which was like a brick of like salt.
Oh.
And I would bite off chunks and eat it like religiously.
And I found out 20 years later, they got recalled because they cause brain damage when consumed by it.
I was not even getting there.
Wait.
Why did no one stop you?
Why?
Dude, I would bite off chunks and give it to my little sister too.
Oh my god.
You made your little sister.
You have to bring her down with you.
I know.
Well listen, she went to college and made the family proud.
I'm playing Mobox with Doki Burst.
Okay, but you...
You...
Okay, but like...
Because she ate it once, you know?
You were continuous.
There's a camera.
Yeah, I got that lamp.
That's legendary loot.
Is it?
I don't know.
I was just wondering.
I just wanted it to be special.
Maybe if it ate a salt lamp, maybe it is.
Okay.
Wait, that...
You can't open that.
Yeah, I don't got a key.
Alright.
Number 10.
Yeah, I didn't buy us a key.
I wanted to save money.
Cause I don't think we're...
That's okay.
Don't look at it.
Okay.
I remember.
She's Doki Burding.
I'm Doki Burding right now.
Sorry, I dropped out of college.
Don't scare me.
Jesus, that was loud.
It's why you didn't go to college, right?
No, I did.
I did.
For a time.
And then I made 10 bucks off of Twitch.
And I was like, you know what?
I don't make 10 bucks off of college.
Dude, and also the first thing I did when I got monetized was...
Don't go in that room.
That's a bad room.
I turn around and you're a smear on the floor.
Do you remember what number we were at?
Oh!
Yes!
This one!
Look!
See?
I definitely knew that.
Yeah!
Thomas is sticking out!
Thomas the Tank Engine just scares at me.
His eyes are so lifeless like he was not sculpted by a creator.
He's seen...
He's seen some things.
You know like Roblox creators can make like...
Sorry.
There's a spider crawling around.
You know like...
Roblox creators, they can...
They make like six figures off of Roblox content.
What?
Yeah, I know.
We chose the wrong career.
What the frick?
Are you kidding me?
Yeah, no, I had a guy...
Came to me at a meet and greet at off guy.
And he was like, hey, like I make Roblox content.
I was like, oh cool.
How much do you make?
And he's like, six figures.
That's actually insane.
And they should be proud of that.
Cause like dude, stupid kids spend their Roblox.
Yeah, I'm gonna be spending Roblox soon.
Okay, it's this door.
It's number 18.
Yeah.
Yeah, apparently the best paying 3D job you can do as a 3D content...
Like a 3D maker is to make models for Roblox.
Wow.
Yeah.
Wait, that's actually crazy.
Cause I mean, somebody made a chibi dokey model in Roblox and look at you.
You bought it.
I did.
I spent 3 Roblox on this.
Look at you.
You got Thomas the Tank Engine right here.
I got Thomas the Tank Engine.
He's like a parasite.
He's just like attached to you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He just started it.
I'll be like...
Choo-choo, chibi.
Choo-choo.
Hey, come on.
Again!
Okay, I'm never opening doors.
You're a freaking victim.
I'm a victim.
Is your health okay?
Sure.
We're fine.
We're so fine.
Okay.
Oh.
It's a big room.
Oh my gosh.
Look at all the money.
Hopefully we can find a band-aid for you keys.
Yeah.
Just put a...
Put a band-aid over my open gaping flesh wound.
Whoa.
Everything will be okay, right?
It's like when people...
Like when you get...
Oh.
Can I ask a question?
Yeah.
What is your bird noise?
Because you know some birds go...
And some scream.
Yeah.
What is your bird noise?
My bird noise?
Oh, I can do a really good crow.
Yeah?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Watch this.
Wait, I can't...
How do I light my candle?
Okay, I guess we'll be in the dark.
That's how you say candle.
You go candle.
Cando.
Oh my god.
How do we get a...
Okay, wait.
Wait, what's your best bird noise?
Wait, how did you light your candle?
This is...
This is not a candle, my dear.
Wait, wait.
Can you light my candle?
Oh, yeah.
I'll light your candle.
Yeah?
I've never made it this far.
I'm a throw.
Okay.
Watch this.
Wait, watch out.
Watch out.
Okay, I think there's a bird in your room.
I think a crow just attacked her.
Oh my god, are you okay?
It's like a crow getting pelted.
Yeah, yeah.
Before he fucking stabs you.
Like, yours is like so majestic.
And I'm like...
Thank you, dude.
I'm known for being...
Oh, wait.
There's another key.
Oh, we gotta find another key.
Key time.
Oh, I found it.
I found it.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, it was right on the desk.
It's like just there.
Sitting there.
Okay, if I die first, you're gonna have to clutch this.
Wait.
If you die...
No.
You're gonna have to clutch this.
If you die first, I'm dying too.
Alright, you gotta live on for the family legacy.
The bloodline doesn't stop with you.
My bloodline went sideways.
You are disgusting.
Look, I seriously think...
You know, like, the goblin mask?
Yeah.
Like, I seriously think that's Thomas.
He's just taking over you.
He's turning you into a monster.
Wait, what's...
Where's the door?
I don't know.
Is there a door?
I don't think that was...
Yeah.
I don't think that was the...
No, it wasn't.
Look.
It's blurred out.
Okay, down here?
Where's this where we came from?
Yeah, down here, down here.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There it is.
Oh, Jesus!
The Thomas emerging from the darkness.
It's so creepy creepy.
It's like...
Choo-choo cheesy.
Choo-choo.
What?
It's the same...
I'm scared.
Someone needs to like...
This is a safety concern.
I swear to God, if the spider comes out in one of these drawers, I swear to God.
Oh, a lockpick!
You want a lockpick?
Oh, wait, wait.
No, you should have it.
Yeah?
I think you're gonna live on and continue the bloodline.
I don't feel so good right now.
Oh, frick.
We need to get to an anvil.
Maybe there's like a 7-Eleven...
Oh, frick.
Oh, what was that sound?
Oh, oh, oh!
There's a spider somewhere!
Oh.
I think it's on you.
Psst.
Okay, there's like 17 spiders on us.
I'm not even kidding.
Do you feel them?
Sure, they are.
Wait, I think you need to turn on the light.
I'm not lying!
Wait, hold on, let me move.
Dude, if you saw my wire management right now, I think you would have like...
Are you okay?
Alright.
I don't know.
I feel spiders crawling inside of me.
I can't deserve that.
What?
I deserve that.
Oh.
Oh, I see the eyes.
They're looking at you.
Oh, hey guys.
Oh.
They're fans.
It was on Dolky Bird?
Oh my god.
Wait, what do you call your fans?
Idiots.
Wait, is that your fan community name?
Well, it really depends on the day, because sometimes it'll be incels, sometimes it'll be disappointment.
It really depends on the vibe we have going on.
Cause listen, the words they call me are so unacceptable.
Like what?
They call me...
They call me cocky strokey.
It's actually disgusting.
It's disgusting.
Wait, where did that come from?
There had to be a story though.
There's not.
They literally...
No, no.
There is a story.
You're not telling me.
It doesn't just come out of nowhere.
I...
Something happened.
Do you recall that?
They like to call me names that pissed me off.
And that one just happened and it really, it really did.
Oh, so did you like get one guide and then...
One guide said...
I don't know.
Let's move on.
What's your favorite color?
Did you get one guide and now it's there forever?
Let's move on.
What's your favorite color?
Oh, that's a lot of eyes.
Oh, I got lockpick.
Wait, I got beer too.
You got beer?
Yeah, I got beer.
Want some, little child?
Oh, yeah.
I'll have some.
Dude, you drank it.
It was so loud.
Oh my god.
There is...
There is reduced motion.
If you press tab.
Thank god.
Reduced...
Oh!
Yeah, thank god.
That shit was bothering me so much.
I believe in us.
You think we'll beat this game?
I think...
As long as something scary happens.
Oh.
I think...
Wait, what room is this?
We haven't seen a monster in a while.
Oh, that's true.
We haven't seen...
Okay.
Oh no!
He's listening!
Wait, wait.
Okay.
I don't do well in these.
I don't...
I need you to know I have died to this level.
Many times.
Take my hand!
Can you hold on to my Thomas?
Go left!
It's left!
Okay, I'm on left.
I'm...
The music is so lit.
Okay.
Okay, it's straight!
Oh, it's straight?
Sorry, Pride Month.
God.
Pride Month's over.
It's okay.
Oh!
God, they're trying to dab me up!
Did you make it?
I made it.
I'm okay.
Don't worry.
The adult is here.
Thank God.
I need Thomas, dude.
I need him.
He's my emotional support.
You know the best part?
Is that my Thomas is sticking out of me.
Wait.
When you look down, it looks like you're kissing his head.
He's a good boy.
It's like you're whispering in his ear.
So fucking creepy.
Okay, there's a chest here.
He looks like he's sculpted out of mashed potatoes.
He's so freaking creepy and lifeless.
You know they rebooted Thomas the Tank Engine?
Really?
They made him a child.
Wait, wait.
Listen, hear me out.
Yeah?
There's two rooms in this room.
Which means one of them is real and one of them is fake.
This is your redemption.
You can figure out.
Okay.
No, it's okay.
You want me to go?
I believe in you.
I believe in Chibi.
This is your time.
Yeah.
I did it.
What?
Dude, I should do it.
I should go to Vegas.
Are you okay?
Do you live?
Yeah, you live.
If I have fingers, I'd be doing the choice freaking gesture right now.
I can tell like you don't pay attention to the lights.
Don't look.
Everything bad is happening to me right now.
Oh, don't look.
What?
Where's this?
Where's this go?
I don't know.
I think we gotta find the lever maybe?
Oh, is this the lever again?
Oh, there's Jorzo.
Okay, if that guy...
Did you say there's Jordans?
No, dude.
Are you Jorking it?
Look, I found some juice.
Oh, yeah.
It's heels.
Oh.
I'm smelling colors now.
What color are you smelling?
Purple.
I knew it.
Wait, are we supposed to do anything now I'm here?
I think we should...
Oh!
I found it, I found it.
Oh, we found it?
Where did you go?
Yeah, it was in the corner.
Okay, now we go back up.
Alright, I'm back up already.
It's so dark, it's so creepy.
Oh my god!
The
second I saw you, I heard, psst.
I thought it was you and that it was an actual spider, you motherfucker.
That's disgusting.
That's so messed up.
You'll never know if it's me or the spider.
You'll never know.
It's so messed up.
It can be anyone.
That $1,000 mic makes it sound real.
That's the only reason why I invested in $1,000 mic.
It's when I went because of Doris.
Yeah, so I can be the best fighter in Doris.
Alright, I think this is the last...
Oh, it's...
Oh!
It's Stranger Things time.
Okay.
It looks like a, like a salami stick.
I might be dead.
Okay.
We have to get the books.
I'm dead.
No, you're not.
No!
We still gotta find all the sparkly books.
Yeah.
God, it's been a hot minute since I've been in the library.
Were you taken?
I'm like in the ocean right now, looking out into the sun.
Okay, seven, four, okay.
I believe in you.
I believe in you, Chibi.
My child.
You got this.
Thanks, dad.
No?
I hear a book.
Oh yeah, you know Espanol.
I can res you!
Do I have enough money?
Yeah!
Res me!
30 Robux.
Don't we have PSP?
Did you res me?
Did you do it?
I'm under the water.
I'm drowning.
There's your body.
Did I res you?
Sure.
Let's just say that.
Wait, I got you up!
I did it!
Yeah, you did it.
I'm so proud of you.
Wait, oh my god.
Thomas is sticking out.
He's watching the door for you.
You sure did, champ.
You sure did.
I'm really glad because I thought I just died.
No, no.
You did it.
You did it, buddy.
Thomas!
Okay, I know you have a res.
Wait, does it cost real money?
It cost Roblox.
Wait, so I spent 30 Robux on you?
Yes.
Oh, quick!
Okay.
That's my dog, Princess.
You don't bite.
You're good.
Alright, so...
Apparently, they made it so that you can't...
You can't fucking stay in...
Stay in the cupboards longer anymore.
See?
Oh, no.
Chibi, you better tip your ass back into this game.
Okay, okay.
I'm doing it.
I'm gone.
Guys, could you please donate one dollar?
I need my money back.
Guys, I need my money back.
Are you serious?
I'll distract him.
I'm sprinting.
It didn't work.
Okay, you go find the code.
I'm in the cupboards right now.
Okay.
I'm looking for books.
I'm playing a rhythm game.
Lock the frickin.
Okay.
I think the rest of the books are up there.
Oh, my God.
Let me out!
This is so sad.
Okay, you better be finding these codes.
I'm barely playing a rhythm game.
I'm just gonna walk past you.
I think the books are up here.
Okay, did you find them all?
I don't know.
The salami mommy is after me.
Okay, is he?
Okay, thank God.
All right.
He left.
Okay, I think the books are...
What's the code?
You need to get the map.
Oh, there's a map.
Okay, there's like the...
It's at the center over there.
The left side.
Or left.
Oh, I see it.
Okay, I'll go get it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You go get it and I'll be at the code area.
I think you have all of them.
Who's he pissed at?
He's...
Oh, hey, Doki.
Me?
I think...
I don't think he likes you.
I think he's a hate watcher.
Oh, my gosh.
Nice.
Let me run an ad real quick.
Any exposure is good exposure.
Yo.
That is true.
Okay.
Okay, I got the paper.
It's...
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I'm playing a rhythm game still.
Come on.
No.
Okay.
It's...
What is it?
Uh...
Goodbye.
Oh, God.
We're missing a book.
Goodbye.
I'm gonna die.
It's up to you.
It's up to you, Chibi.
It's up to you!
Wait.
He's stuck on a wall.
He's freaking gritting.
Oh, no.
He got out.
I'm gonna res you.
Oh, frick.
He's pissed off.
Oh, my God.
Are you...
Free loot.
Oh, nice.
Oh, that's awkward.
What is it, Chibi?
Aren't you gonna res me?
I'm right there.
I don't think your God's favorite little barrel is still rushing.
What do you mean?
I...
I see a heart floating there, Chibi.
I see...
Nothing popped up.
I see a heart that's floating there.
What do you mean?
What do you eat?
It's just...
It's blank!
There's something...
You fucking...
I'll remember this.
Yo, that was your loot?
That free loot was yours.
Oh, frick.
I found your candle.
Okay, okay.
I think...
I think I'm missing one freaking book.
I'm getting one book.
Okay, just force it.
Just force it.
Okay, brute force.
Okay, it's uh...
What's the code?
Seven...
Question mark.
We know seven...
Two...
Five...
Seven...
Two...
Five...
One...
Four.
I don't remember.
You gotta remember.
Okay, seven...
Seven...
Two...
Five...
What is it now?
One...
I miscalculated something.
Yeah, you know, you don't know one, so you gotta, like, reinforce the second one.
So it's seven, and then whatever number you want, and then two, five, one, four.
No, it's seven, seven, two... Because it's seven, two, five, one, four.
Seven, two, five, one, four.
Oh my god, I'm just gonna read your paper.
Seven, two, one, five, four.
Seven, two... Seven, two, five, three, four.
Seven, six... Okay, it's seven, six, one... That's an X, not a star?
Seven, six, one, three, four.
Oh!
Oh, I thought that was a star.
Okay, I'm missing a book.
How do you... What?
Seven... Seven...
Two, two, five, one, three.
And then we just guessed.
Pick a number.
Three.
Nope.
Okay, and then you can do it again.
You keep doing it.
I'll keep watch.
Okay, okay.
Seven, two, one... What was it?
Seven, two, one, five... No, it's eight, zero, zero, eights.
Or five.
Wait, really?
Yeah, eight, zero, zero, eight, five.
Oh, fuck!
I put the phone on!
Seven... Seven... Two... One... Five... Nine?
Yeah.
Don't worry, you're fine.
He's not near you.
Seven... Two... One... Five... Six.
I'm gonna go find the book.
I'm gonna... I think... I think it's like right over here.
Trust.
Okay.
You can do it.
No, no.
Just proof force it.
You can literally proof force it.
You're literally one.
You're in this chest.
One number!
Don't worry.
I'm keeping watch.
You won't die.
Okay.
Seven.
What is it?
Seven?
Seven, two, five, one, and then just go number... Go up by one.
Okay.
I'll do... Three.
And then you just keep going up.
Seven... Seven, two... Five, one.
Don't worry, you're fine.
He's not near you.
Seven.
Two.
Five.
One.
Eight.
I feel like I am watching a child right now.
One.
Six.
Seven.
Two.
One.
Five.
Seven.
Two.
Five.
One.
There's only nine numbers.
I don't understand.
There's only... There's only nine numbers.
Seven.
What was the second number?
Two.
Five.
Am I good?
There's no keys.
There's no keys right there.
Am I good?
Bro, that's
cute.
He likes me.
Actually, I can't believe.
Seven.
Two.
Five.
Not
you.
Just go by...
Oh, what do you mean?
Just go up by one every time.
I just do it with the heart now.
Two.
You tried two.
You did two twice.
You put two in there twice.
I'm not gonna put two a third time, Chibi.
I did eight.
I already did eight in nine.
You did six or seven.
Seven.
Two.
I already did nine.
The monster just ignores it because he's just too strong.
Four.
Seven.
She's too small.
Two.
Seven.
One.
What is it?
Seven.
Two.
Five.
One.
Three.
Try three.
No.
What do you mean no?
Did you try three?
I did.
Okay, four.
We go up by one.
This is like simple numbers.
Try four.
Okay, try four.
Have you ever tried the game?
Are you smarter than a fifth grader?
I'm just wondering.
Yeah.
Did you beat the game?
No.
Which grade?
Four, right?
Four?
Four, yeah.
Four.
What if we're doing the code wrong?
Okay, you do...
No, what?
Seven.
What do we need?
Count Dracula.
Oh, seven, two, five, one.
Yep, seven, two, five, one.
Have you tried four?
Wait, I don't think we've tried five.
Okay, trash.
I swear to God.
If we just went from zero to ten.
Zero to nine.
Okay, okay.
Okay, now I'll do six.
Okay, if we did six, didn't we?
Oh.
You just haven't done...
Seven.
Is it seven, two, five, one?
You want to do seven?
Yeah.
Okay.
There's no way it's seven.
It's not seven!
Seven, two, five, one, six.
Okay, six.
Apparently six.
It's gotta be six.
Six or one.
Oh!
Maybe it's one!
Oh my God.
If it was one, we could have started on the number one and this would have been over.
It was one, wasn't it?
It was one, wasn't it, Chibi?
It was fucking one!
It was one.
We could have started at one.
Why did you randomly pick, like, eight?
Because I had a seance!
I think God was speaking to me.
Or at the gas leak.
I don't know why.
God was speaking through her.
I'm sure it wasn't, like, a false prophet.
I think it was a demon.
It's kinda been a demon!
Okay, now, now I'll walk in.
Look, I'll speed run.
I'll speed run.
Okay, I'll believe in you.
Look, I'm gonna go super fast.
Brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrrr.
Brrrr, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr.
Brrrr.
What?
Oh.
You're fine, see?
I need no worry about it.
You're fine with me!
I don't...
I...
You have ears!
She...
What do you mean?
What?
You're dead.
I am dead.
Humans?
I'm allegedly a human.
It's okay.
Your mom paid me extra for overtime.
Yeah, shut up to my mother.
She worked the pool.
Yeah, I was there.
Humans.
That's where I met your...
Your neck was the pool.
That's where I met her.
Are you my actual dad?
Cause my mom jokes about me not knowing my real dad all the time.
And like, it gets to the point where like, I'll laugh and she just will laugh.
I don't think it was a joke anymore.
No, that's what I'm thinking.
Are you my dad?
Are you actually my...
Are you gonna...
Are you gonna Mamma Mia it?
Where like, you have multiple...
You don't...
There's multiple people that could be your dad.
And you invite all of them to your island.
No!
I've never seen that movie.
Oh, me too.
I've never seen it.
But the premise is apparently like, the same as you.
She's just like you.
She doesn't know her dad.
But like, her mom...
She's just like...
I think you should've known her.
She's just like you.
And her mom...
Like...
Had...
Had like multiple...
Encounters.
With multiple men.
Hey, listen, listen.
And then she was...
She's about to get married.
So she invited all the men that her mom slept with to an island.
Um...
And they...
Trying to figure out who is the real dad.
Jerry Springer!
Who?
The guy is like...
You know like the guy...
I think...
I'm even getting it wrong.
But the guy who like...
Who like...
It's like you were not the father.
And the guys do backflips and stuff.
Yeah, yeah.
He like...
They like...
Entrapped them all on an island.
And the only way to get out is to...
Sing ABBA songs.
Oh!
Yeah, he's like...
That sounds kinda lit.
Here we go again.
My, my, my...
What if I just play a copyright song...
Through my mic...
On your...
Honestly...
I'd let you do it.
Because I seriously don't care anymore.
I showed gaping airplane butthole on my stream.
You think the standards...
You know like how...
You know like some Twitch streamers...
They don't care.
They just use the band as like a vacation.
Cause it's like...
You know...
A three day vacation.
It's like...
Sorry...
Uh...
Spider inside me.
I've never gotten a band before.
Yeah.
Please...
I cannot tell if it's you or not.
It's actually...
It's messed up.
I can't...
I can't tell.
I can't tell too.
You're looking around.
Stupid.
What happened?
It looks like you're...
It's there right now.
I know that was you.
No, I know that one was you.
That actually was not me.
What?
What do you think?
I'm being like...
This is like...
I feel like I'm in a toxic relationship.
Oh, so like...
Just like you're...
Yeah, I know, dude.
Which one's the pinky daddy?
A flashlight!
Listen, my mother was a party animal in her days.
Yeah?
But listen.
Listen.
At least she left the house.
She gave word to a daughter who...
I'm playing Roblox on a Saturday fricking night.
Like what the frick are we doing?
We should be out like getting lit.
Right?
What?
Wait, so when was the last time you were out getting lit?
I...
You know the last time I went to...
It's easier to say it than the two.
The last time I went to a party, it was...
High school anti-prob with theater kids.
Oh my...
Wait, you were a theater kid?
Yeah, I was an improv kid.
Oh my god!
I explained so much.
No, like I don't have a bath.
I just want to explain that.
I just explained...
At least you weren't a bad kid.
No, it was not.
Those guys were wild.
Those guys...
I know, they were like t-pose and like whipping Nae Nae.
They were like...
They were like actually whipping it.
Yeah, they'd like t-pose and go, oh my god.
It's in the middle of class.
Oh my god, you're at 62!
Yo!
Mods add...
Wait, one...
Mods add me.
Add seven more.
Did you get the key?
There was a key on the second drawer.
What would I do without you?
Were you the voices speaking to me?
Are you gone?
Pick it up!
No!
I can't get it!
Oh, I got it!
I had it that whole time.
Maybe we should turn it off...
Turn on child mode.
Child mode?
You...
You want that?
No, I said child mode.
Oh, I thought you said chat mode.
I was like you...
I'm good in here, right?
Yeah, you are.
You're in the room.
Good, cool.
You don't know me.
Oh?
Oh, Jesus.
Whoa!
That's some...
That's...
That's your dad.
Oh, no.
No, I'm kidding.
I love my dad.
If that was my uncle, I'd be scared.
Alright.
Oh!
There's the room.
Okay, there's...
There's...
Yeah, but that one has the key.
Oh, so it's this one?
Yeah.
Okay.
Good.
Thank you.
How did you know that?
I didn't.
I just...
I took the camera.
I 50-50'd it.
Oh, I took an edible.
I'm getting lit!
Oh, shit!
Go outside!
Oh!
I'm getting lit!
Flush!
Oh, frick!
Wait, what are you...
What are you supposed to do in this room?
You just go forward?
Oh!
Every time it, like, goes crazy on your screen, you have to turn around.
Ah!
Oh!
Oh, it's this one!
Yeah!
Oh, I just see...
Oh, so you are...
You're literally fighting your inner demons, because all I see...
I took a Benadryl.
All I see is just you in the hallway, like, just running back and forth.
That's literally all I see.
Like, it looks...
It's the hat man.
Have you ever seen him?
No, I've never seen the hat man.
Well, one time...
One time I took a Mucinex and I played patty-cake with him.
Oh!
No!
He won.
Oh, frick!
You got this!
You're almost there!
Wait, I think I did it!
Yeah, you did it!
Yeah!
Ah!
Why did you look back?
Why...
Why did you look at it?
I...I don't know!
Because I was turning around in the minigame.
It was, like, instinctual.
Watch this, I'm gonna time it.
Alright, I'm watching.
Okay.
I'm watching.
Yeah, he left.
Watch this.
After the stream is over, I'll send you a clip.
Why is this going to scare you?
It's for eight-year-olds.
Like, what the frick?
Don't worry.
It definitely looked as bad as how it does.
Look at our profile pictures.
Like, look at you.
It definitely looked as bad as what you think it is.
Did I just die?
Did I even... Was I close?
Oh, I'm sure you were, sweetie.
Dang it.
I just needed to make it one more room.
Oh, no.
Not nice.
Oh, wait.
I actually went back to the lobby.
Oh, that's okay.
All right.
I'll wait for you in the lobby.
I like people watching in Roblox.
Have you seen some people's avatars?
Oh, yeah.
I know.
Some people have seen avatars.
Okay.
Why does it look like I'm pooping?
Do you see this?
What?
It looks like I'm pooping.
Oh, wait.
You look like a... Oh, wait.
Oh, my God.
You look like a goddamn shrimp.
With ass.
My wife showed a baby.
You look like you had, like... It looks like you got, like, a Brazilian butt lift.
Oh, yeah, dude.
Yeah.
Yeah, but you only... I'm actually raising... I'm raising sub money.
But you only focused on the butt.
Yeah, the thighs don't match.
Yeah, the other... Nothing else matters.
It's just the butt.
Oh, my God.
Did you see that?
Did you see Lucy?
Oh, Lucy... Lucy went for, like, an actual Brazilian butt lift.
Actual B... Well... Yeah.
I don't know.
I feel like the only reason I would get a BBL is because I'd use it...
Oh, hey, it's your friend.
Oh, that's Queso.
What's that front?
Yeah, it's your friend.
Yeah.
Oh, hold up.
Hold up.
Oh, shit.
Hi.
That's my mod.
That's your mod?
Your Queso?
Yeah.
Yeah, Queso's my mod.
Lord PuszPusz?
Yeah, Lord PuszPusz.
Is he also 40?
Actually, I don't know how old he is, but he sounds like the doctor from TF2.
So he's, like, he's, like, 60 then.
Oh my god, it's Dragon Ball.
Oh my god, is this real?
Oh my god, are you real?
At chat, are you real?
Grog, is this true?
At Grog, is this true?
What movie is... At Grog, what show is this?
Oh god.
Is that Goku, guys?
Oh my god, it's Goku, everyone!
Whoa!
No, I think it's Piccolo.
It's DokiBird69, I missed her.
Yeah, let's get DokiBird69 here, and we'll do an Endocarius.
Yeah, DokiBird69, get in here.
Join Chibu's lobby.
One of the Doki's will succeed, right?
Yeah, eventually battle it out.
Okay, if your name has a Doki in it, join our lobby.
Yeah, and then we'll have a four... Yeah, yeah, we'll get the Dokiverse in here.
Dude, you know how many parasocial people from your chat are downloading Roblox right now?
It's okay!
I said the Dokiverse.
It could be either of us.
Dude, I'm eye-level with Thomas.
Yeah?
You want me in the bags?
Oh, bleh bleh bleh bleh.
What were you doing to Thomas, Chibi?
I was giving him a check-up.
Oh yeah, by the way, remember when you get older, you gotta check your prostate or you get prostate cancer.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, actually true.
You also need to practice for the exam.
Yeah, you...
You gotta study for it.
You gotta practice for it.
If you know how to check for cancer, you don't have to pay the doctors.
Exactly.
Check yourself for lumps.
Yeah, check yourself for lumps.
Just...
It's actually true.
Guys, we're not fucking with you guys.
The older you get, the more likely you'll get prostate cancer.
So you got...
Yeah, it's really common.
Yeah, it's very common when you're older.
It's like girls should be checked for breast cancer.
Guys, go get your kidney holes touched.
Yeah.
It's easier for the girls because we...
Because we're so old.
Have you ever had a mammogram?
No, have you?
No, I have not, but I'm kind of looking forward to it.
To be fair, I feel like you'll need to.
What?
I feel like if there's a lump, it'll like protrude.
I'll go up a cup size, is that what you're saying?
God dang it!
You'll know when you look in the mirror and you have breast cancer.
My boobs will look like cottage cheese.
Like, God dang it.
There's freaking Owl Odie behind me.
Yeah.
Look at him.
Oh my God, he's twerking!
Guys, I think those are all our fans, Guys, change your name if you want to join up a lot.
Hold on, I'm gonna stop speaking to them.
Hold on.
You guys gotta change...
Do you actually have the mic option?
Oh, I do actually.
Oh, I'm scared.
I'm scared of the children.
You guys are losers.
I just had someone...
Which one's mouth breathing though?
I'm scared we need to go upstairs.
This is why I don't have the mic option because...
First off, I'm scared children will talk in my...
Like, children and I don't want to...
It's all my...
Oh my God, there's...
Guys, I don't think this is for...
I don't think these are for my fans.
I think they're your fans.
Don't worry, I'm in a chair watching in the corner.
You cock.
I'm looking...
Hashtag Sneeko.
Where the freak are you?
Where did you go?
We're gonna go lockdown!
Yeah!
All right, and he...
Oh my God, see...
Now that's an avatar right there.
All right, any Doki's?
Guys, if you want to join us, you have to have a Doki name, guys.
That's the whole point of the Doki verse.
We have, like, new ch...
New members.
Who the frick is this little baby?
Look at this infant.
What the frick are you?
Are you trying to fight another...
Oh my God, look at this!
There's an actual baby in here.
Now that's a baby.
Punt it.
Yeah, punt that child.
All right, any Doki's?
I don't see a Doki yet.
I see another Goku.
Oh, I think we're nobodies.
We're...
I'm Doki in spirit.
I'm not breathing, I'm scared.
Look, I don't want a Minecraft situation here.
I...
Oh, that implies a lot of things.
This is what...
Like I said, this is why I'm afraid of turning on...
Turning on the mic option.
I didn't...
I never turned it on, it just...
Who did they whispering at me?
Some kid just like, you should be Super Mario.
You should play Super Mario 3.
All right, I started the...
Yeah, I gotta go.
God just told me to play a...
Super Mario 3.
All right, since there's no Doki's, we gotta do a two rumor.
Maybe next round, maybe next round.
Yeah, next round, maybe next round.
I can't get the...
Goodbye.
No, you're in, you're in, don't worry.
Don't worry, you're in.
You're in.
Don't leave me here, Michael.
Don't leave me here with my demons.
All right.
Let's see.
I do have...
Oh, actually, the...
No, we're fine.
Yeah?
Yeah, what are you doing?
I'm warming up.
All right, we're in.
All right, our best...
Our best room was 68.
That's our first attempt?
Yeah.
That's our first attempt, right?
That's not bad.
Yeah, that's pretty good for you.
You really spent like 400 Robux.
Yeah, and then we spent like 60% of that time in that room trying to guess the number.
Who would have possibly known it was one?
Who would have possibly known?
I don't know.
I would have started at...
I would have honestly started at zero.
So, instead of randomly choosing seven, I don't know.
According to my calculations, there was no way it could have been one.
Oh my god, that's bad apple.
What is it?
Oh, but...
No, no, no, no, no.
Ever on and on?
That is such a good song.
I used to listen to that song and play Minecraft.
Bad apple?
Yeah.
Have you actually played Toho before?
No, but it's been on my playlist since I was like 10.
The games look so freaking cool and I love the music.
Yeah, the music's really...
I've never actually played Toho either.
I don't even know what the plot of Toho is.
I know it's like everything because there's like a lot of games and a lot of characters and it's like supposedly really good.
Like there's a lot of characters and stuff.
Have you played the horse game yet?
I downloaded it yesterday, but I decided I want to play it on stream with chat since they really like it.
Wait, even there's multiplayer?
There is?
Wait, oh, you mean like you play it on stream.
Oh, I'm parasocial.
I'm parasocial.
Yeah.
I'm a freaking loser.
You're parasocial to your chat.
I'm gonna have a collab room if I'm yours.
You're not.
I thought you meant like racing like chat chat.
Let's see who has the best horse.
Oh, there is multiplayer.
Oh, there is?
Yeah.
All I know is I like the girl with the like gold and something who has like white hair and she looks up the camera.
Oh, gold shit?
That's that's that's her name.
Gold shit.
I don't know.
I never played a gold ship.
Yeah.
No ship as in like a boat.
Oh my god.
I was like...
I don't even know it because it's like on my it's been on my Twitter feed apparently like she's like apparently like an actual really good horse and because they're all named after real horses and stuff and she's like a little shit.
She is a little shit though.
And like very like silly and like random.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, there you are.
I'm here.
Peek-a-boo.
What?
Okay, now I don't know what that was.
I...
What?
Let's move on.
No, I just I'm having issues and I already have like mental like...
I mean you ate salt.
So...
I did.
I also ate crayons.
Wait, what?
Dude, they smell good.
I've eaten a lot of you.
Wait, how old were you?
Not that old like 10.
Okay, so that was not bad.
No.
It's up here.
Don't go in this door.
Do not.
Oh, I don't.
I...
Don't worry.
I know.
Dude, is that what got you before the guy would grab you?
Yeah.
Oh, uh...
Yeah?
Eh.
What's in the Roomba?
Did we both try to steal each other?
Oh, I'm dead.
We got in too early.
Wait, did you die?
I need to die.
Give me the back shots.
What?
You're ripping his waist.
I didn't die.
I got in too early.
Because I thought he was right behind us.
Wait, did you die too?
Oh wait, you're alive.
Rez me.
Rez you?
Okay.
Rez me.
Wait.
Oh my god.
I can kick you around.
Rez me.
I have...
I have all.
Rez me.
Yeah, come on.
Oh, thank you.
Hey.
You know...
You know you...
Where'd you go?
I had Robux.
You owe me.
That was like 30 cents, dude.
Wait, where are you?
I don't know.
Where the frick are you?
I'm in a room with paintings.
Wait, me too.
Wait, where are you?
Wait, are we desigged or something?
Wait, where...
Wait.
You're trolling me again.
There's no way.
You pillow princess motherfucker.
I'm doing the puzzle.
And you're watching from the sneaker chair again.
I just don't know where I am.
Where the frick are you?
I don't know.
I got money though.
I spent 30 cents on you.
Nice.
Chat.
I will never financially recover.
Chat, can we get a gifted sub?
Wait, I see you!
You're just...
I see you're in the darkness.
Where are you?
Get all the way over here.
I don't know.
I know that was you because I heard the frickin' spit on your lips motherfucker.
And I know that was you too.
Okay, do you know why I know it's you?
Because you're louder than the actual game!
You're like 2 times louder.
I know that was you.
What, what, what?
That wasn't me?
I think that was a spider, whoa.
You're like 2 times louder than the game.
Isn't that...
Are they not coming?
Oh, it is.
Alright, we're good.
I wasn't up to anything nefarious.
Let us continue on our...
That like took so long though.
That was like actual forever.
Sorry.
Demons.
Don't worry, your inner demons.
Aren't you used to that though?
Your entire existence is like fighting your inner demons.
I took my vitamins today.
My mom gave them to me in a piece of cheese and everything.
Yeah, and then if you don't hear...
No, if you don't take your meds, chat...
If you take your meds, chat will disappear.
They literally have a command to time themselves out.
So whenever I do take my pills onto...
Like my vitamins when I forget...
Yeah?
Everyone leaves.
Yeah.
Everyone just do exclamation point bad.
Yeah, it's really freaking sad.
Cause it's like seeing like my dog get put down.
Oh shit.
They just all just go away.
Oh, you are...
You are a parasocial.
Uh, dude, it's...
It's sad.
Like all I do...
It's...
It's so freaking pathetic.
I think it's so freaking pathetic.
I wouldn't say that.
Why?
Oh, hey, it's right here.
I like how if you take too long, though like it starts glowing.
Like, cause we're like kids.
I know.
You're like...
We're like eight year old.
We don't even know where the buttons are.
We need a yellow paint right now.
Alright.
This game needs some yellow paint on the doors.
I swear to God, if I turn this corner and you're a smear.
I swear to God.
I'm okay.
Are you?
I'm...
I'm alright.
Here I am.
I'm okay.
Alright, it's this one.
I just heard a...
Alright.
25.
Apparently it was not 26.
Who would have thought?
Ooh.
I'm sure we don't need that.
Okay.
Oh, it's here.
Oh, I don't like that.
That's creepy.
It's so dark in here.
Yeah.
I think that's where you just go for it, though.
The silhouette of your tank engine makes me feel a lot more safe.
Oh.
I don't know about that.
It's so dark.
What the fuck?
Where the fuck is the light?
Oh, there it is.
My turn.
Oh, I don't like that.
That means...
Oh, wait, no.
This is the running one.
We're fine.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, okay.
We're gonna have to start running.
Alright.
I might die, though.
I'm not very good at this one.
No, you won't live.
Alright.
Show me where we have to go.
Okay.
I'll...
Sorry.
Hold up.
Wait, wait, wait, hang on.
Move baby!
Yeah, we're here, baby.
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow!
Have you ever tried seeing Tibi?
Uh, yes, but then everyone told me this shot-off.
Okay, but who's everyone, though?
Who's everyone?
My mom.
I- I don't know how to sing.
I sing for fun.
Have you ever- Oh, shit.
I'm okay.
Hold up.
Look at you, you're a pro.
There we go.
I'm alive.
Have you ever tried doing a karaoke stream?
Um... Well, the thing is, I- I want to, but I'm- I am, like, I don't know how to sing.
Okay, but how many subs will get you a karaoke stream?
I would do it for free.
Oh.
Yeah.
Unless people want to give me money, then $10,000.
For free or $10,000?
I'm a streamer.
I want money.
I feel like cats are food motivated.
Streamers, dude.
Streamers are money.
I think we'll be fine here.
Yeah, see?
He doesn't know how to go into rooms.
Stupid.
Yeah, stupid.
What are you?
A child?
Okay, let's not throw around that one.
Dude, the spiders hate me, dude.
Stop.
I can- I- I like- Like, I can tell sometimes when it's you, but I still check.
Like, when you're like, I know that's you.
Can you really tell, though?
Can you really tell when I go- Stop.
Women scare me, dude.
They never know when they want to eat food and they go- Women scare me.
Are you okay?
Yeah, I just remembered you're a woman.
You just thought about it.
It's like, holy shit, I'm collabing with a woman right now.
Are you good?
Yeah, I'm good.
I thought you forgot about it.
You're just like, woman!
Tits, tits, tits.
Just think about tits.
I don't remember that.
You know something about women?
We never forget.
That's true.
It's so dark in here.
I found the door, I found the door.
Nice.
Oh, I found a bandaid.
Oh my god, it only does that much.
Just one bandaid.
Oh shit.
Oh shit, what hit me?
What hit me?
It means something hit me.
Oh shit, it's the eye.
What are you doing?
Get the fuck off of me.
Wait, what is my head doing?
Why am I, like, motorboating the floor?
Why did he die?
I'll never be a good person again.
Dude, you died of cringe.
I tried to res you, and the moment I was trying to res you, the fucking... the spot it showed up.
So I was stuck in the loading thing to get you up, and then the spider fucking ran at me.
Dude, my character's twerking.
Do you see this?
Ding!
She's throwing it back.
Do you see that?
I can't see it because I'm fucking dead.
What do you mean?
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Go to the lobby.
The lobby?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So we can see if there's any other jokies.
Yeah.
Alright.
Alright, where are the jokies?
In the jokieverse.
How do I go to the lobby?
Oh, it's returned to... yeah.
Alright, are there any jokies?
I saw CoolKid69.
Oh, heck yeah.
Nice.
There's no jokies yet.
I can't believe it.
The jokies69...
They don't like us.
jokies69 added you, and then never showed up.
That's fucked.
Maybe it's my dad.
Ooh.
He never showed up.
He never showed up?
Don't worry, he'll show up.
He just...
You love your dad, that doesn't exist.
No, no, my dad's in the other room playing...
Playing...
What's it called?
It's okay.
It's okay, you don't have to lie.
You don't have to lie to us.
It's okay, we're...
He's playing Clash of Clans.
We're here for you.
You don't have to lie for us.
We're here for you, chibi.
He's playing Clash of Clans on his iPad while watching the gold digger show.
Where they dig gold.
It's okay, chibi.
We're here.
We understand and we listen.
Thanks, dad.
Thanks.
We're here for you.
Chat can be...
Wait, actually, no, that's bad.
What?
Chat can be my dad?
Yeah.
Oh, Jesus.
That's gonna...
No, I can't...
That's a pipe one.
No, that...
I don't think you're not...
You're not at that extent yet.
You're not there yet.
Give it a couple years.
Give it...
No, give it until like...
Give it until...
Until your...
Your...
Anniversary.
That's super...
That's still...
Oh, shit.
Hey, that's...
Oh, I got the name.
The name.
That's a job application.
No, look at the name.
Which one?
That one?
Oh, jeez.
Which one?
Matt?
Or the job application?
No, the job application.
The job application.
Look at the name on the job application.
And that's in reference to Diddy Kong.
From Mario.
Grow up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Diddy Kong with, like, Paulina.
I love Pauline!
Yeah, but... but then they replaced Diddy Kong.
He literally took her job.
She took her... took his job.
Wait, did they really kick him out?
Yeah, they kicked him out.
Yeah, you know.
And they made Donkey Kong wear pants.
Oh my god!
DonkeyBird69!
Wait!
Okay, join us!
DonkeyBird69, join us, join us.
DonkeyBird69, get over here.
And there's another one!
There's someone named DonkeyMon.
They're a cosplay agent.
Oh, okay.
We're DonkeyMon.
That's perfect.
Alright, join us.
Four people.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, ready?
Three, two, okay.
Only Doki's in.
Wait, okay, wait, wait.
I saw it!
Get out, get out.
The Doki's gonna get in.
Okay, we'll try again.
Okay.
Okay, get in here, get in here!
Oh, which one, which one?
Get in here!
Doki, get in here!
This one?
I'm with the Doki, I'm in!
The Doki FPS VTuber!
Oh, wait!
There you go.
Get wrecked.
There we go.
You see as you lose.
Get the frick out.
There we go.
Oh, we got... Someone... I have to reconnect.
I'm inside something.
What?
Wait, I couldn't even get in the game.
Wait, I got disconnected.
Hey.
I got disconnected.
I just saw your boobs.
Okay, we have to make a new lobby.
Okay, you have to leave.
No, I'm staying.
I'm on a date right now.
Hey, wait, wait, wait, wait.
This is a Doki lobby and you're missing one of the prime Doki's.
I'm on a date right now.
With your dad?
No, no, this is... You don't know her.
She goes to a different chat.
Oh, she lives in... She lives in Canada, right?
Yeah, you wouldn't know her.
She's just a cute girl.
I literally live in Canada.
What do you mean?
Oh, break!
I literally am living in Canada.
Hey, uh...
I gotta go.
I don't... I've never made it this far.
I'm gonna throw up.
Alright, I left.
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, they have to join us again.
Alright, Doki's!
Doki's, we're ready to try again.
Assemble!
Doki's, assemble!
I'm building a team.
We have a Doki.
Oh my god, well, because we have two other players, we can make them spend Robux on us.
Okay, so you're... Guys, you're not allowed to do anything except follow us?
Have your tail between your legs, don't sweep them unless you open to you, and buy things for us.
Oh my god, Peter Griffin!
Wait, I want him to be on our team.
I want him to be on our team.
Yeah, I'm following his lobby.
I want him on our team.
We have Doki's and Peter Griffin.
I like him.
Oh my god, wait!
Oh my god, that's my dad.
This is my dad.
Oh my god, bring your kid to work day!
Yeah!
Family photo!
And then Goku's behind you.
Oh my god, me and I have my child right here.
Chibi Doki.
When do I grow my train?
Let's go.
Don't talk to me or my child or my child's child again.
Peanut.
Oh my god, they're talking to each other.
Yeah?
What is he saying?
He said, why'd you invite me?
I'm trying to eat my food.
And then he ran away.
I don't know, I feel like I'm listening to a conversation I'm not meant to be a part of.
If they are willing to publicly have a conversation in Roblox, it's free.
It's free game.
That's true.
Why would you...
There's a reason Discord is around.
Why would you choose Roblox to talk to people?
We need to go, a man just spoke to me and I'm scared.
There's Chibi...
Oh, there's Chibi guy.
There's a Chibi person here.
I think that's a regular guy.
Come on.
Come on, Peter.
Wait, Doki Mom's here.
Okay.
We have Doki Mom.
Wait, we're still missing one more Doki.
This guy goes, hello, Chibi.
And I go, I'm scared.
He goes, you shouldn't be scared.
I'm scared.
I'm scared for you.
I know.
Oh wait !
It's Doki plus Peter.
Alright, get in here, Peter.
Okay, get out.
Get out.
Yeah, that's not Peter.
Peter, couldn't get in.
Get out.
Peter.
Couldn't get in.
All right, come over here.
Where are you?
I see.
Okay, go.
Go, go, go.
Get him.
Get Peter!
No!
He says evil!
Get out, get out, get out!
I don't say evil!
Let's go share.
Go, go, go, go!
Where's Peter?
Wait, where's Peter?
No!
Where's Peter?
Peter left!
He left us!
Peter left us!
No!
Alright, Doki's only now.
Yeah, Doki's only.
Everyone else gets on shock attack.
Okay, I couldn't get in.
I don't think these guys are Doki's.
I don't think these are Doki's either.
Oh frick, I joined the game.
Okay.
Side quest.
I got a side quest.
You got a side quest.
We left Peter.
I'm so sad.
We don't have Peter anymore.
You are not Doki.
We only want Doki.
Wait, wait a second.
Okay, you can stay.
You can stay.
I can't believe Peter left us.
I know.
I can't believe it.
Someone said Peter too big and then he disconnected.
Maybe he's changing his phone.
Peter's too big.
Peter too big.
What the frick is this?
Wait, where are you?
Doki.
Do you see this?
Which one?
Do you see this little head?
Do you see this little head with my face on it?
Where?
I don't see it.
On the floor!
Wait, I like this.
I like the speeder.
Wait, let's put this Doki with us.
Alright, Doki's.
Doki's get over here.
Doki's.
Only Doki's in the Doki verse.
Okay, here, here, here.
This one.
Go, go, go, go, go.
I couldn't even...
Okay, wait.
No, no.
That's not...
One of them is like Baku.
Baku, go, go, go.
Wait, I'm not in, I'm not in.
I got out, but you said you're not in.
They tried to go over again.
Oh, there you are.
You're in it right here.
This one.
Wait, they go in.
Wait, wait a minute.
Go, get out, get out.
They go in when I sat near an elevator.
Okay, we sat in the middle.
Okay, we sat in the middle and then we find it.
Okay, ready?
Okay.
Are you ready?
You see the other bit I'm looking at?
Yeah, I do.
Wait, wait I'm going to open.
Wait, how am I left?
Peter's back.
Peter.
Peter, there's here.
Oh my God!
Okay.
Okay what if...
Hey, okay?
Peter, Peter, Peter... Go, Peter, lead the way.
Yeah, Peter, Peter!
You go to the elevator!
We follow you.
Peter, you are a leader!
No, you- go...ario we follow there!onne asked!
Get out!
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh my God!
I got up... I got up, doctor!
What the fuck is Peter?
Wait, he's here with Peter.
No, no, I'm coming over.
I'm coming over.
Don't worry, back in the lobby.
I think we need to create a private server.
Oh my god, that was so funny.
The fear.
It was so real.
We just want one thing.
Women just want one thing.
Yes, Peter Griffin train.
Peter Griffin has a train.
I want it so badly.
I'm trying to join the lobby, but I think the lobby is full.
I can't just yell at me and say, Cheapy, you're gay.
It's fake, I can't just... It's your lobby.
Okay, okay, I'm gonna join a random doors lobby.
You gotta join me because everybody is trying to get up, get into our lobby.
We gotta go quick.
Alright, alright, I'm in.
Alright, I don't think...
Okay, I'm joining you.
Alright, okay, okay, I'm here.
Oh my god, they're all waiting.
They're all waiting.
All these jokies.
Peter, where's Peter?
Peter, get your ass in here, Peter.
Get your... Oh wait, there's normal Peter.
No, I won't train Peter.
No, he's not good enough.
He's not good enough.
Where are you?
I see you, I see you, I see you.
Okay, okay.
Let's pick a room, let's pick a room.
Okay, let's just settle for jokies.
Here, here, here.
Okay.
Okay, that's a Doki.
Wait, I think that was number one Doki bird fan.
I think that's fine.
Okay, oh my god, they're...
They're not even a Doki!
Okay, okay.
We try one more time, one more time.
Wait, this isn't good enough for you?
Look, you have a cosplayer!
No, look at the other ones!
The other ones are just a regular name!
What's their name?
Zayn!
What the fuck is that?
I'm turning my mic on, I'm turning my mic on.
Zayn disconnect.
Disconnect, leave now.
Disconnect Zayn.
Leave now.
Get out of my life.
Leave!
Okay, nice.
Did we sign
him off?
Oh no, we're gonna be his 13th reason!
Jimmy, how did you turn it?
Jimmy, that's so fucked up!
Listen, listen, it's this kid's make-a-wish.
You're gonna be the mad 13th reason!
How would you live with yourself, Jimmy?
Listen, skill-based matchmaking, little fucker.
I was just joking.
I was just joking, guys.
Guys, it wasn't me.
Slash J.
This is their make-a-wish.
To hang out with you.
Yeah.
So you need to make sure it's a good experience, okay?
Yeah, yeah.
I'll be the cameraman.
You guys gotta like...
Okay, you have to open every door first.
You're the front line.
Okay, Doki?
Alright, open that door.
Open- You're failing your first- Open the door!
Open the door!
Did you know if you say any bad words with Roblox chat, you get banned?
Oh yeah, that's true.
Yeah, oh my god.
Someone was like, my experience with Doki, Google Doc.
Dude, one time I was playing Dress To Impress, and I wanted like, to like, everyone to start over, so I said, everyone get naked.
I got a 3 day pants.
I got a 3 day pants!
My God!
Fair enough, seeing get naked in Roblox is not a good one.
I'm like, I...
Yeah, like, you know there are children in this...
Fair enough!
I'm bad!
I've been like in the game!
That makes it worse!
What do you mean?
It's a dress up game!
Get naked...
It's like, it's like when people were like, I hope you die in Minecraft.
That's, listen!
Listen, I've said that before!
Take off your clothes in Minecraft.
Okay, wait, that actually does sound really bad.
Yeah, yeah!
Yeah!
And then, yeah!
Oh frick.
Yeah, and then it does sound really bad right now.
What did I find?
I got a battery.
Oh, lick it.
Lick it?
Yeah.
Which end do I lick?
I think you can do both ends to make sure you're... make sure you get...
Your body will take a screenshot.
Oh, that's true.
What the frick is that noise?
What do you think it's that noise?
Something's laughing.
Do you frickin' hear that?
What is that?
Oh my god!
That's a child.
Wait, what?
Oh my...
What happened to me?
It just bean dipped me and ran away.
It ran at me in the closet.
The frick was that.
Wait, what?
Look at that.
Oh, it's the eye.
Oh, there's an eye now, yeah?
Yeah, it like took half your life, right?
Yeah, it did.
Yeah, how do you avoid it?
I think that's the wrong way.
Okay, Doki mod is not living... Doki mod is not doing what she was supposed to be doing.
You will be shot to death if you do not get us from one...
Thick!
I'm almost dead.
Me too.
You will be executed if you do not.
We will replace you with another Doki.
The Doki Primes are angry right now.
Yeah, we're mad.
We're mad.
I'm looking at you and I can't believe you're the...
Oh, it's another eye.
Two eyes in like, level 12?
All right.
Um...
Doki, open that door.
Nevermind.
Okay.
Yeah, he's okay.
Doki, go towards that door right now.
Which door?
Right here.
I like...
Wait, did you told him you're replaceable?
No, but I can tell him that if you want me to.
Okay, yeah.
Okay, do it.
There's plenty of Doki's in this verse.
Okay, hold on.
Hey, listen in, motherfucker.
You iPod freaking cheeto dusted apple juice smear on the lips.
Motherfucker.
I have had kid playing Roblox on a Saturday night.
You will be with VTubers too.
We'll be VTubers we could buy your family, sell them and buy them again.
Don't keep me head.
What the frick are you doing?
You will lead us.
Oh, I got banned.
I got ban- I got warning.
I got a warning for saying come to the end.
We've detective language that Violet's Roblox created.
Wait, you could have cursed him out in Espanol.
I don't think the Roblox detection...
Okay, hold up.
Yeah, cursed him out in Espanol.
Let's test it out.
Okay, I'm gonna say one thing, okay?
Yeah.
No, say many things, so then we'll...
Alright, now... I didn't get a ban.
I didn't get a ban.
Yeah, alright, go off on him.
Do it.
Pendeja caliente pinche puto.
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah!
Say some more stuff.
Chibi, you will get banned.
Oh, oh.
No, no, say more.
No, you won't.
You'll be...
I can't even click out of it.
Why the fuck did you listen to me?
Are you...
I got banned!
I got hip popping up!
I can't believe...
Chibi got banned in Roblox.
It's sad.
It's not the first time I was playing Roblox Squid Games, and that game pisses me off so much, because the kids piss me off and start yelling.
Yeah.
And we do not like that.
Hello, little guy.
Oh, oh.
Whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Don't worry, we're in that room.
Wait, what's that?
Goodbye, DokiFan.
Wait, is he good?
Oh, he's good.
Yeah, he's good, he's good.
Good night, sweet child.
Fish.
Nice, why did he go under the bed?
I think he's scared of you.
He's nervous, you know?
He's so nervous, yeah.
He's got the full outfit and everything.
Yeah.
It's like his dream to get yelled at by the Doki's.
Doki Square.
Wait, wait, wait.
I can't...
Doki, pick a room.
Pick a door, right now.
Doki.
Doki, stop going to drawers.
Pick a door.
You can't talk to him, you got a bad room.
Open it.
Oh my god, they took it!
He's dead!
Alright, revive yourself.
Alright, this way.
Alright, goodbye.
You're stupid.
You're so...
You're so stupid.
You'll fucking revive yourself.
I gifted you a fucking revive.
Yo, easy 30 robux.
That's karma right there.
That's actual karma.
I'd like to apologize to Doki Bird fan.
I don't.
I live.
Zero consequences.
Not there yet.
Nice.
Look at that.
Okay, so...
Let's go.
Oh, it's this way.
Alright.
What?
There's a spider on me, be careful.
Oh no.
If you get too close to me, I'm gonna get Ligma.
What's Ligma?
I found it, I found it.
On this.
Boom.
Yay!
Alright, follow the door.
Alright, choose the door.
No, oh.
This way.
What?
Choose the door.
Oh.
You're so lucky.
I was like...
Alright.
Oh, we're almost there.
And the next one is the running one.
Oh, it is.
It is.
I really hope we see DokiFan make it to the end.
I'd be so sad if he doesn't knock through the door.
Yeah.
He's so freaking sad.
I'm ready.
I went the wrong way.
Oh, wait.
Straight.
Okay.
What?
You're a pro.
Just follow the voices.
Let them win.
Straight again.
What do the voices say?
Straight.
Okay.
I got it.
I'm doing it.
She's locking in.
She's pressing field.
I'm so locking in.
I'm going left and right.
It's like this game is made for children.
Oh my god.
Dokimon made it too.
They did it.
What a Chad.
Okay.
That was actually impressive.
Dokifan.
Yeah, you did it.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh.
Is there items here?
No.
Oh.
I found some piss.
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh, wait.
Can you drop it?
How do you drop items?
Oh, here, here.
I can drop it.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cause you're full HP cause you died.
Here.
Freaking rap.
Drinking, drinking piss in the van.
Like, what the frick?
That's how I like it.
Yeah.
Is your guilt.
Oh, it said door open.
Oh, they did it.
Nice, Dokifan.
You did it.
You're making all us Dokifans proud.
I know.
See, this is why we have you around.
And why we did- Why we did cyberbullying off the game.
Like the other guy.
Well, I will.
I will.
Only if they perform adequately.
Otherwise, they're gone.
They're fucking gone.
The thirteenth reason will be you.
I'll get more than a three day van.
Are you good?
I'm ready for- Alright.
Are you ready to spend your Robux?
Are you- Oh, frick!
I'm not- You know you're lucky.
Spend your Robux.
Where's that?
Come on!
Did they do it?
Are you good?
Wait, what the frick?
What the frick?
Wait, are you good?
Are you rest?
What is that?
Is that you?
What the frick?
What is that?
Are you okay?
Were you alive?
Who was that?
Are you alive?
I'm under the water.
I'm dropping.
You died!
You actually died!
Oh my god!
I'll just let you know, Chibi, I've been rest and I'm ahead of you guys.
I was... I was ahead of you guys in the room.
I'm meaning this not to be edgy or offended.
But you're effectively turning me straight.
And it's just a disrespect.
Wait, you both died.
You both died!
The disrespect for woman is insane.
I'm changing my preference on Tinder.
You both died.
Oh my...
No, walk in, walk in.
Are you okay?
I can't believe you both died.
I... This is so freaking disrespectful.
That's actual karma.
That's karma.
And by the way, I was asking my audience for like, uh, dirt on you.
I could yell at you whenever you laugh at me for being stupid because I knew it would happen.
And all they had to say was you're a Marvel rival, you're an Overwatch fan.
And I was like, but the frick, that's all she's got on her?
God dang it.
You see it, Chibi.
When I was growing up, I didn't eat... I didn't eat salt or... Or licked batteries growing up.
There's always tomorrow.
What, tomorrow?
I'm just gonna start licking some... Dude, do a mukbang stream where you just eat salt and like, licked batteries.
That's weird.
I heard like, I actually heard it, but... But it didn't show up.
Ooh, that's weird.
Dokimon just said, Chibi, this is your fault for cyberbullying.
I'm about to... Shut up.
This is your... Shut up.
You're not gonna... You're gonna... Shut up.
You're gonna... Don't lie.
Psst.
Don't give a hat.
What's your Twitch username?
I didn't know what number we were at.
What's your... Prick.
What's your IGN?
Where am I?
I'm trying to ban him.
It's...
Shibidoki and... Are you... Are you... Are you trying to ban him?
Tell the world your plans.
He said his username is Shibidoki.
That is not freaking true.
Alright.
We realize this Doki might not be the right Doki for this... For this game.
But you have Thomas.
You're never alone.
That's true.
Psst.
That's so true.
At least Thomas will be here for me.
Oh, there's a flashlight on that desk.
I don't need a flashlight.
Oh my god.
She's hurt.
I'm... I'm hurt.
She's go keep hurting.
I'm gaming.
I think this is about to be play of the game.
Alright.
Okay.
I swear to god.
If you get this done really quickly, I'm gonna be so freaking pissed off at myself.
Alright.
How many gifted subs?
On my channel.
Not on Shibid's channel.
On my channel, like a hundred gifted maybe.
Keep it, you know, humble.
Yeah.
Just a hundred, you know.
Just... Just a low hundred.
Are you good at stealth games?
No.
You literally... You literally saw me die like immediately.
You've got this.
Do I?
I don't know.
I just, you know, want it to like make you feel good.
You know, like cheer you on a little.
Oh, nice.
That's cool.
I didn't really need it, but...
Wait.
Where are they?
Where are the codes?
They make little glitter noises like...
Where is it?
Oh, I got money though.
Where the fuck are they?
Let her cook, shh.
I'm cooking, I'm cooking.
Jessie, stop touching my balls.
What?
I can't, Mr. White.
It feels really good.
Where the fuck?
Sorry, that was just a bonus episode of Breaking Bad.
Yeah, I never watched Breaking Bad.
It's pretty good.
I watched like the first episode and I got so depressed because the guy got cancer.
Yeah, actually that show...
No, it's actually really sad.
Yeah.
It is.
The first episode made me too depressed.
And I was like, I can't do that.
Well, like 10 years ago I read a spoiler that...
I read online that Walter got cancer.
And I thought that was a spoiler for the show.
So I was so pissed off I didn't watch it for 10 years.
And then I finally sat down and watched it.
And I was like, wait, that's not even a spoiler.
I can't believe he got cancer.
I can't watch this anymore.
Well, cause I thought that was like the big twist.
Remember to check your prostate.
No one starts with cancer.
That's why he became a drug lord.
Yeah.
That's his whole shtick.
Okay, why did you think he became a drug lord if it wasn't for cancer?
I didn't know anything about the show.
I didn't even...
Like, I literally only knew that he was bald.
So I just ate and had cancer.
That's all I knew.
What's this?
Okay, I need...
Sir, I need...
Star, square, triangle.
Okay.
Where are the books?
Mr. White, what do the books say?
They go, they sparkle like...
I hear it too.
Oh, here you go.
Okay, we need two more.
Or one more.
Okay, it has to be up front.
Cause I...
I looked at all of them here.
She's cooking.
I'm cooking right now.
Oh, that's so creepy.
I'm still cooking.
Oh, I found another...
Looks like you're like muffling Thomas' face in the door.
Like your curb stomping him.
Is that okay?
Cool.
Alright, there you go.
It's...
Okay, it's...
Three...
Six...
Two.
Okay, three...
six...
Two.
Okay.
Is this guy blind?
Is he blind or something?
Now you know how I felt!
Oh wait, he actually is blind?
Yeah he is!
Did you try one?
Yes, that's the first one I did.
That is actually the first one.
You tried to?
I did that already, don't worry.
Oh frick.
I'm going up by...
3, 6, 6...
2...
There we go.
Okay, chat, who did it faster?
One for me, two for...
Okay, who do you think did faster?
Who do you think?
The one that put 7 twice?
And I wanted to put it in as the third time?
And then I was like, Jimmy, why do you want to put...
put in...
7 again?
Because baby it was 7.
TokiFPS VTuber YouTube TT.
Oh my god.
This guy is taking fucking forever to get here.
Holy shit.
God, the way Thomas just looks out the closet.
Alright, where's my 100 gifted memberships?
On my YouTube.
Alright, TokiFan.
Get on that.
TokiFan.
Alright, Tokis.
Come on.
Where's my 100 gifted?
That was...
Literally carrying the Tokis on my back right now.
You actually are.
This is like natural selection.
Do you think...
Do you think I should go where it says humans?
I think that's the store.
I think it's okay.
This way, humans.
Humans.
Welcome to the underground.
Show us your balls.
Oh.
Oh look, it's the freaking lone wolf.
Humans.
Hey!
Oi!
Oh!
Careful of the tentacles.
Alright.
I have the key.
I have a flashlight.
I have a cross.
What does a cross do?
Um.
Maybe it like keeps you alive or something.
That's what it does in like phasmophobia.
Oh.
Wait, I don't have enough.
I only have four.
I'm not spending my money on you guys.
That's not...
Understood.
I get it.
It's not the first step.
No, it's fine.
I understand.
Listen.
Women be shopping.
I get it.
Alright.
Where's...
Oh, there's the key.
Nice.
Nice car.
What did you say?
What?
I said nice job.
Oh.
I heard...
I heard something completely different.
Wait, what did you hear?
I can't say it.
Oh, no.
What did you hear?
I heard you say...
I can't say it out of the word.
No, no.
What did you hear?
Wait, what?
What did you hear, Chibi?
Chibi, what did you think I said?
Chibi?
Come on, Chibi.
Come on.
What was it?
Here, instead I will perform as a gesture and entertain you while you...
Here we are, Chibi.
I will entertain you.
No, Chibi, no.
What did you think I said?
I'm actually curious.
What's this?
What did you think?
Your reaction was like, what the fuck?
Oh, I prefer...
Okay, give me a hint.
Give me a hint, Chibi.
It...
It rhymes with...
Flock.
What?
I thought you said nice.
Beep.
Nice...
What?
You know, nice, um...
Sock.
What's wrong with that?
No, but like, it was a different word that sounds like similar.
So what was it?
What?
A male chicken.
Rooster?
Teeth?
Oh, seven?
No, the frickin' slurp.
Jesus, you slurp so loud.
Whoa, that's weird to say.
Say it.
What's wrong with saying it?
I don't understand.
Nice phallus.
That's what you thought you said.
Blink, a different word for it.
Blink, what's a different word?
I can't...
Blink, maybe I'll say it on Roblox chat.
Should I spell it?
Okay, yeah, I spell it.
I'm confused.
C-O-C-K.
What is that word?
I thought you said that!
Because I did.
It was a prank saduko with my eyes closed.
Like, none of it mattered.
None of it mattered.
Watch out, there's a shark in there.
Got him.
It was very believable, wasn't it?
I genuinely thought you didn't know what that word was.
Yeah, you actually was, like, trying to teach me.
I felt really smart.
I was like, nice, I know something.
I'm so intelligent.
Nice.
Nice rock.
Oh, which room is it?
What room?
Pick a room.
Any room.
Why did I just pick this room?
I don't know.
What's there?
I heard feet.
Nice.
Nice stock.
Nice rock.
I can't tell that light was, like, because sometimes they do, like, fake lights.
For the monsters.
So I can't tell.
Okay, 64.
Alright.
Dokimon.
Was it 64 or 63?
It's 64.
Trust.
This is your time to shine.
Okay, I said Dokimon.
Sorry, I speak what's wrong with you.
My bad.
Why do you speak for him?
Right?
Okay.
Wait.
My right or your right?
Okay, 64 or 63?
Tokimon.
69.
Alright.
See, I told you.
I never lied to you.
Wait, is that the... monster light or...
Yeah.
Yup, yup.
How's this?
Alright.
Now we're in the painting room.
Wait, this is our PD almost.
Peanut butter.
Nice.
Alright.
I know we swapped these two.
Where am I in the Doki food chain?
Because I... I'm, like, an honorary Doki.
My name is Chibi, but my last name is Doki.
So, like, am I, like, up there?
Do I... do I have any respect?
I feel...
Oh, that's... that's cute.
What?
Do I have... like, like, do people look at me in the eyes when they speak to me?
Or do they chuck, like, hammers at me?
Like...
It's like a spectrum.
You're like... okay, you're like...
Okay, you wanna know where you are in the Doki food chain?
Yeah.
You're like...
You know when, like, you know, they're like...
You're like, Chibi Doki entertain us.
And then...
You're the tiny little jester.
And then Jax is in front of all the Doki's.
You're the...
Did I start busting it down?
No, we just...
You know the most...
Saddest thing part.
No, you know, like, that breakdance...
Is it breakdancing Garfield?
Like...
Oh, yes!
Break.
Yeah.
When I was a kid, my mom convinced me that I was really good at the robot.
So, every family function for, like, 10 years.
You just do the robot.
They would surround me and go...
Like, watch a white girl catch a groove, bro.
I would be busting down the robot.
And...
One time I was dancing in the kitchen.
Hey, wait.
Before you go on the story.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I beat you.
Nice.
Nice sock.
Look at that.
You're in a creepy room.
I'm in a creepy room.
But anyways, long story short, I'll keep it short.
I was busting it down, white girl style, in the kitchen.
And my mom ran in from the patio.
Cause she thought I was having a seizure.
And...
That's how bad I am at dancing.
Like, when I twerk, it looks like I'm a mosquito drinking blood.
It's bad.
Oh, where do these doors go?
Where does this door go?
Wait, so they didn't call the hospital?
Well, she was on the phone and came running in.
And she thought I was seizing.
She thought I was seizing.
But no, I was just busting it.
Oh, I know I'm running past the wall by the door.
I was checking the items out.
So you're like...
So we basically...
If the other Doki's wanna be entertained...
Um...
We like...
What we do...
Yeah?
Is basically, we're like, bring in the entertainment.
And then we like, pick you up.
And then just drop you into the center of the circle.
Surrounded by all the Doki's.
And we just watch you break down.
Why aren't you dancing your banana outfit?
Roll out the chibi.
I'm like the freaking Scrappy Doo of the group.
Oh, you are!
That is like...
Oh my god.
That is the perfect example.
That's actually...
Oh.
Wait, how do I do this?
I don't know.
I actually don't know.
That's kind of scary.
He's like jumping in the distance watching you.
We can't see that.
I don't know how to do this.
I...
I don't know.
I'm so confused.
I'm actually...
I am so confused.
She just falls over.
I guess...
I don't know.
I can't read.
That was like actual cinema.
I can't read it.
That was beautiful.
Alright, we go to the lobby.
We need another doki.
We need another victim.
Where's Peter Train?
Fina.
Fina, the horse is here.
He's like a cat.
Oh my god, Lois.
That reminds me...
You remember?
From the time?
Did all the doki's die in doors?
Holy crap, Lois.
What the frick are you?
Wait a second!
Why does this person have a better chibi doki model than I have?
Yeah, this is... Can we have... Can we invite this chibi doki?
Okay, let's get... Wait, I thought you were banned.
How are you unbanned?
Oh no, wait, am I unbanned?
Yeah, you're talking.
Oh.
I see like the microphone.
Hey.
Oh my god.
I like your outfit.
Hey.
Are you rizzing yourself?
Would you...
Okay, if there was another chibi doki, would you like...
You know, take your chibi doki to home run?
No, because that would be so pathetic that like that's...
That is the situation that I would only ever get that far, number one.
And number two, God, I have freaking standards.
I know the way I am.
No, absolutely not.
I'd like...
Absolutely freaking not.
So someone else has to lower their standards to...
Yes.
Absolutely.
It's like...
Satan is playing limbo with the freaking bar.
So, so...
Yeah, they have to lower their standards.
To go past first phase.
Wait, if someone else is willing to lower their standards, why aren't you willing to lower your own standards?
For my...
Well, okay.
Because, listen, I...
If I was with myself, that would be the worst...
That guy is...
Sorry, Ducky.
Do you see Ducky running on this guy?
Yeah.
I'm giving him a lap dance.
I...
Dude, if I lowered my standards for myself, that would be such a bad relationship because I don't clean or anything.
Oh, yeah.
Who would be the cleaner?
I know.
It'd be bad.
Oh, my God.
Wait, are we one?
Wait, look at Doki for...
Do you see this?
Oh, Doki.
Okay, yeah.
Okay, get over here.
We need that Doki.
Get over here.
You're the chosen one.
You're the new Doki.
Follow us.
Alright, we need...
Alright.
Follow us.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
We need to...
These three.
These two.
Okay, Aubrey Doki.
Follow us.
Doki stroky.
Okay.
Alright.
Come here.
Are you ready?
Alright.
This one.
Okay, come on, get out, get out, get out.
Right here.
Right here, right here, ready?
Okay, here.
Go, go, go!
Hey, hey, hey!
Wait, you pick a room.
This one, this one!
Okay, okay, wait, wait, wait.
Get in!
Why aren't you in?!
I told you wanted the dookies!
That was one of the dookies!
Oh, I told you wanted all the dookies.
Oh my god.
I'm leaving.
I'm coming back to your lobby.
I'm coming.
Hey.
Uh I...
Okay.
Pick.
Okay I'm here.
I'm here.
Pick a room.
What the frick is this?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
This one!
Oh my god okay.
You've gotta try.
You have to try again.
Okay.
One of the jokies has... What's it called?
Chikawa, hummermermer.
Got it.
Okay, okay, okay.
Ready?
Pick another.
This one.
Alright.
Good or no?
Yeah, good.
It's fine.
That's fine.
Oh, who's that?
Okay, I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't care what's it.
I want to play with these two.
Alright, don't worry.
We can end up.
Okay.
Nice.
We got the Dokis.
It's a Dokis squad.
It's a full Dokis.
We're good.
We have... We have Aubrey Dokis.
Yay, your favorite.
It's the medic.
It's the medic from Team Fortress 2.
Wait, this person, they're saying hi to us.
Hello.
Alright, we have all the Dokis.
This is it.
We're gonna hit 100.
100.
100 doors.
We got this.
Sorry, I had to establish myself as the Alpha.
The Alpha Dokie?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, the Dokie Prime.
We are the Dokie Primes.
What we say is law.
Oh, my God.
This is a pay-to-win Dokie.
They bought extra items for us.
I want it.
Give me.
What is this?
Lead the way.
I don't know what it is.
I don't know.
Oh, my God.
Look.
She bought so much stuff for it.
Look, look.
There's another one.
Drink it.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Drink it.
What does it do?
Whoa.
Does it make you faster?
I don't know what the frick that is.
I don't even know what it does.
Oh, that felt good.
I don't know what that was, but it felt good.
What is it?
We're getting lit, like I said.
Oh, it's health.
What?
That was health.
And she was like, please use it only in emergency.
And we chugged it.
Use only in emergency.
And that was... I don't think the Dokie understand.
It was an emergency.
So I was really thirsty.
Yeah, we were so thirsty.
It was probably like 10,000 freaking coins.
You got to go.
Dokie, where's the keys?
Okay, go away.
Why are we doing work, Dokie?
Get over here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's sit over here and commentate.
We're the entertainers.
Yeah, yeah, we're the entertainers here.
Let's drink our piss and watch these peasants.
Oh, yeah.
Are you drinking again?
I have no problem.
Shut up, my uncle.
We're sorry.
This Dokie has a problem.
Has a drinking problem.
Did you use it all up?
Chibi?
Wait.
This person's saying that this guy died.
Wait, really?
Wait, what?
Oh, oh, they said they died.
They said they died.
I don't know.
Wait, what?
I think he had it with us drinking the...
You don't sound like a club-yard boy.
I think it's because...
Have a good day.
I think it's because we kept drinking...
We kept drinking his items that he left us.
He's had enough.
Oh, wait.
Do we cyber-book another fucking camp?
Okay, we need to be really nice to this Dokie.
Because this is like...
This is crowd...
No, no.
This is a stress test.
We're stress testing the Dokies.
If they can't handle us...
If they can't handle us, they were not meant to be a Dokie.
They revoked their Dokie card.
Yeah, they have to change their cosplay.
Yeah, they have to change it.
This Dokie is screaming.
You're scared.
Why are you scared, Dokie?
Come on.
Do we work?
Yeah, keep up.
Come on, keep up, Dokie.
This is our third attempt.
Get your ass over here.
I can hear my voice in their mic.
I hear it.
I hear the voices, Ma.
My ears.
They're so cute.
Alright.
There it is.
Wait, they're so...
Where are they?
Where did they go?
Wait, where did...
We lost our Dokie.
I don't know, but the last thing I heard them say was...
I sound like a 12-year-old boy, but I'm actually a girl.
I swear.
I've been there, dude.
It's like, child or female.
Oh my god, dude.
Oh my god, I had...
I'm clearly a female.
I had a game.
Do you remember Dark and Darker?
Yes.
Okay, so there was a time I was playing Dark and Darker.
And then I was talking, like...
You know, the best part about Dark and Darker is when you get to talk to the random strangers.
And then, so I bumped into this guy.
And then...
This train...
I swear to God.
Wait, our Dokie is sobbing in a closet.
I just heard her going...
I'm dead.
I'm...
I'm gonna talk to Dokie, number three.
Hey, do you have any Robux?
I'm dead.
financially.
Wait, DokiFPS declined your revive.
Where's my revive?
What do you mean?
Go through the rooms.
It says, DokiFPS, VTuber, YouTube, TTV, Facebook denied your revive.
I was waiting for your revive.
Okay, listen.
We need to lock in.
What's up?
Alright, I guess it's time.
Okay, yeah.
I'll keep it.
I'll keep it on.
Alright, I'm in the room ahead.
I'm here.
Oh, did you rest yourself?
I rest myself, you fuckers.
I rest.
You said it.
Don't let her revive you.
I was like, okay.
And then I declined her revive so I can accept your revive.
Listen, listen.
I got freaking nervous.
I'm listening, okay?
Wait, wait.
I got you something.
Eh?
Okay, don't fucking waste a flashlight.
We're literally in...
We're in room 18.
I got you a sample of my piss.
Okay.
People spend... Can I have that back?
Don't, don't, don't give it to her.
You're in Doki.
Doki, drop the item.
Doki.
I have a faster internet.
She's saying, drop it.
I, I, but it's like a dog with chocolate.
I don't think you want to have that.
I did, I dropped it.
I dropped it.
She said, how do I drop it and then drank it.
She went, how do I drop it?
Go, go.
Open the doors.
Go.
Go far away.
Doki, go for it.
You clearly...
She said she feels like you're bullying her.
Go far away.
Doki Bird says, go far away.
Go, go far away.
Go.
You will be executed.
Take it.
We will passage you from the Doki first.
We will delete you from our existence if you don't go for it.
They will take you.
They will...
You will be taken to Rumble.
No more...
Ah!
We're actually bullying me.
That was me.
We're so freaking...
In every universe.
In every universe, Doki bullies a child.
There's always...
No, no, no.
You don't sound like a child.
There's always one Doki...
One Doki in the lowest food chain.
Oh, here.
Doki the third.
I bestow a...
Where the frick did you go?
I'm here.
Oh, fuck.
Here, I give the...
Here, you can have that if you can't see.
There you go.
What the...
Did you...
They turned on their flashlight, looked at me and said, Ew, I'm done.
I can't...
The frick is wrong with the...
Wait, are you good?
Are you good?
Did she leave?
Wait, I have a...
Wait, where's the key?
Hello?
Are you good?
What?
What happened?
Where are you?
Wait, I'm making a friend one second.
So I continue...
Speak.
I've lost track of them.
I have no idea where they went.
Why is Doki society so cruel?
It's a Doki Doki world.
Bob Ryan.
What the fuck are you guys doing?
Wait, wait.
Doki Bird.
I'm not even kidding.
This person was being really sweet.
Saying some really nice stuff to me.
They got a freaking warning from Roblox.
From being nice to me.
They got a warning in Roblox.
They said, I love what you do.
And then they got a freaking warning.
They're like, you can't love.
You can't love here.
No love is allowed.
Doki Bird, where are you?
I guess we'll never know.
Where is Doki Bird?
Get in the closet.
Love is forbidden here.
Wait, are you...
Are you good?
Yeah.
Doki Bird.
Yeah?
Our fan is dead.
No, no, don't worry.
She revived in front of me.
I'm partially responsible except in the closet.
What did you do?
You took her closet?
After she told you how much she loves you.
And what you do, you took her closet.
This is truly a Doki Doki world.
This is...
Shit!
This is truly...
Sorry, I'm talking to her again.
A Doki Doki world.
It doesn't matter how much love you give them.
They'll take everything from you.
It's survival of the Doki.
Yeah.
You're the lowest Doki in the food chain.
You deserve it.
You are the algae of this world.
We will consume you.
You are the lowest food chain.
The lowest...
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
I got the key.
Oh, nice!
Bro, that other Doki we had, I think that other Doki was honestly the better Doki out of all of us for this game.
I think they would have carried us.
And then they left.
Oh yeah, the one who bought us the loot?
Yeah, and then they left after you kept drinking the thing.
Listen.
They said they gave up.
They knew after two doors they gave up.
They freaking left.
Oh.
Yeah, this is where we get chased, I think.
Yeah, we can just do this.
Here.
Take these pills and use them whenever they chase you so you'll go fast.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh wait, guys.
Guys!
GUYS!
We're dead.
I was freaking wrong.
I was so wrong.
I thought it was the other guy.
I thought it was too.
Didn't we all die?
Yes.
We all use the reds.
Wait, Chibi, no.
You have one more reds.
You...
You will...
You shall...
Good evening!
I will lead us to Ufri Piss.
Alright, I'll save this when I really need it.
Did you save it?
Then...
Did you save it, Chibi?
Did you?
I'm lagging.
Dude, I feel so smart at this puzzle for you guys.
Alright, I got this, boys.
Don't even worry about it.
Easy frickin' game.
I'm so worried.
Nah.
Ooh.
Slurp.
Alright.
Let's speedrun.
Pretty easy game, so I'll be real quick.
Yeah, it's like this game is made for children or something.
Shut the frick up.
I'm in my element.
But can you be my personal best?
Oh, what was it?
It was like 70 something?
It was 70, yeah.
I got to 69 and then died at 70.
I got...
Voice chat suspended for five frickin' minutes.
What the frick did I say?
What did you say?
What did I say?
Was it the birth?
What the frick did I say?
I think I've only died to like...
Those fucking...
The chasers.
I know!
They are bullshit.
They are so bullshit.
Debs...
Debs, please nerf them.
Please nerf.
Um, they're clearly too strong for this game.
Like, um...
It makes...
My inner...
It makes my child cry.
Hello?
Why are you crying?
My child...
No, you.
You're my...
Your child.
How frickin' dare you?
I am the sole survivor of the Doki army.
I'm a frickin' national hero.
Look.
I don't even need to see which one because I know it's this one.
Boom.
You need to be at this...
At least this height to talk back to...
You're gonna drive me to frickin' drink.
Oh, that...
You weren't drinking earlier?
Even Aubrey Doki.
Aubrey Doki said you're the sole survivor because everyone left you.
Maybe...
You're at the bottom of the Doki chain.
Look, you're getting Aubrey Doki to cyber bully you right now.
Don't!
I can't hear you over the...
Boom!
It's like a cat.
It said...
Heat in my ear.
You guys hear that?
Meow.
You did it.
You did it, Doki.
I...
Should I told you I'm good at this game?
Jack!
Yeah?
You're so good.
Oh, money.
Okay.
Okay, 48.
That's not bad.
Oh, oh, oh.
Hello?
Okay, I think we're good.
The lights flickered.
I thought it was the cheesy guy.
Yeah?
It's him!
Why was he edging it?
He announced himself three minutes ago.
Why did he take so long to pull up?
All right.
All right, you ready?
All right, Chibi, you want to do one more run?
Let's make a team.
Wait, let's build an army.
Let's build a team.
We would've... Wait, your access to chat has been... voice has been disabled until...
Until...
I got, like, an actual, like, month-long ban.
You got a month-long ban.
What the heck?
Who reported her?
Who reported my child?
I'm like... I didn't even say anything bad.
Yeah.
Okay, um...
Maybe it's, like, those delayed... delayed suspension when you were cursing... when you were cursing at the Tokyo.
Oh, maybe when I was, like, yelling at the kids.
Yeah, and then you got reported, and the... the real person looked through the chat logs.
I did say you will be gunned down.
What?
Did you say that in Espanol?
No, I said it in English.
I said...
Oh, you...
Oh, my God.
That might be why I got banned.
I'm sorry for saying I'd shoot people.
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
No, now I understand.
No, I understand now how you got banned.
I was...
That makes a whole lot more sense now.
Alright, I'm in the lobby.
Can we please play with the minion?
Can we please...
Oh, where are you?
The freaking minion.
Where are you?
Oh, I think we're in different lobbies.
Here, I'll join you.
I'll join you.
Okay, okay, okay.
There's so many...
Doodoo.
My mod is playing be a car.
What the frick is that?
My mod is a grown man.
And he's playing be a car.
Freaking grown man playing be a car.
What the frick is he doing?
Is he also 40?
He plays the German one.
Hello.
My gosh.
Schmetterling.
Where are you?
I'm right...
Oh, where are you?
Alright.
Okay.
We need to build a doki army.
Build an army.
Alright.
This time it'll be...
Okay, okay.
We got doki's.
We got some doki's here.
Okay, okay.
Okay, let's go.
The frick it should be doki 69.
I don't wanna...
I don't feel safe with that one.
Okay, wait.
I don't...
Wait, it's Zane again.
Let's get out of here.
No!
Are you ready?
Tell him to leave.
Okay, okay.
But I'm voice banned.
Oh shit, you're right.
I'm voice banned until...
I think I'm voice banned for three minutes.
Okay, okay.
So, you need three minutes and I'll yell at this kid.
Let's do it.
Get out.
Leave.
You're not joking.
You are not Dokie Master.
You're not.
Leave.
Wait, wait, wait.
I got my switch trap back.
Oh, okay, okay.
You must leave.
You're not doki.
Get out.
You must leave.
Leave.
Oh he kicked us out of the other way.
You're not Dokie.
Leave.
Name change yourself until you're a Dokie.
Wait, they said they'll pay money.
Okay, you can only say if when we die, you rez us.
Okay, okay, wait, wait, wait, no.
No, no, wait, wait, wait, $5.
You lost only a collective $10, $5 each.
$5 at Cheapidoki's...
One gift itself on Cheapidoki's channel, and then $5 super chat.
$5.
I'm broke, I'm homeless.
He said he's homeless.
Wait, I gotta talk to him.
I'll talk to him.
Lord, you will use more than your house if you do not give us $5.
Give us $5.
The Toki extortion.
You said this is how you make money in Roblox, right?
Yeah, you said I'll pay you.
Were you lying?
Were you lying when you said I'll pay?
How would you pay us?
All right, we'll only let this person play If they go in front of us at all times.
More like the Mr. Beast of YouTubers.
We'll let this homeless guy play with us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Today, today, we're gonna let a homeless Roblox player play with us.
Distorties!
If you win, if we get to room 100, you get a house.
If not, Rob, find the house.
You get a Tesla and a house.
If not, aww.
If not, aww, you lose a leg.
For every death, you lose a limb.
So lock the frick in, okay?
Yeah.
You think, you think your luck is already bad because you're homeless?
Just wait.
Mr. Doki.
You'll be homeless and without legs.
There's a lot of legs.
Yeah, yeah.
And then if you run out of, we're gonna, you know that like, that manga panel meme where the guy is, the guy is just like a head and like a, the body in the hospital bed.
Yeah, that's what he'll turn into.
That's what you will become.
That's what you'll become if you don't.
Wait, they're running away.
Yeah, no, no, no, they're, remember I said they have to go forward if they want to play with us?
Oh, okay.
So, they're gaming right now.
They don't want to lose their limb.
You're good.
Go, keep going.
They said, please, no.
Please don't cut off my, you're the fucking meme.
Please don't cut off my leg.
Please, I need those.
I need those.
You don't need your legs to play Roblox.
Yeah, you can have your arms.
Oh, I actually went under the bed.
But then like, but then we'll eventually get to your arms too.
Then you gotta start playing with like teeth or something.
Yeah, with your mouth.
You know like the...
Where you can like play with...
I heard it though.
There's like fake ones too.
I know.
Okay, oh, I got the key.
All right.
I got the key.
Thomas looks like he's...
Zane, go in here.
Where is he?
Go.
Vamos.
Pick a door.
Oh wait, there's only one door.
There's only...
I thought it was those like...
Yeah, pick a door.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
I see you.
I see what you want to do.
I swear to God, if I walk in here, you're a freaking smear.
Wait, I gotta go talk to the homeless guy.
Hold up.
Tell them to...
Don't tell them to...
Wait, he died too!
Are you serious?
Hey, you.
All right, well.
All right.
You owe me one.
You owe me a rez.
No, you owe me one.
You owe me one.
That's fucking right.
There you go, there you go.
I know, I know.
I respect the doki hierarchy.
Yeah, I respect the doki hierarchy.
Wait, does this guy not have a rez?
Wait, this guy not.
They sent the face.
So they were homeless.
They wouldn't have rezzed us, they wouldn't have rezzed us.
They said, I'll do anything.
Okay, hold on, I'm gonna speak up.
What will you do?
All right, it's time for the other Doki now to go for it.
Okay, yeah, they gotta prove themselves.
All right, other Doki, it's your turn.
It's time for you to lead.
Go for it.
They're panicking, they're saying, I don't know what to do.
Go!
Wait for you, no, no, no, no, no, don't.
We wait at the top, let's go smoke our cigarettes.
Exactly, I was like, I was like, don't stoop to their level, Chibi, what are you doing?
We wait here, look at that, see?
We're better than them, yeah, let's go, let's just go.
That's fine.
That's why they live down there and we live up here.
Jesus Christ, it's like, it's like a movie plot, you're the bad one.
Yeah, this Doki goes in the coal mines.
Jesus!
We live up top of the mines.
Wait, they never, oh, they're there, okay.
This is classism, classism in my Doki verse.
You must pick a door.
Any door.
All right.
Okay, I spoke to them and they went, what?
How?
You must pick a door.
All right, get out of here, Doki, get out, it's time.
Go for it.
That's right.
Wait, Doki, drop that beer.
Drop that.
Drop it.
Drop it like it's hot.
You press X.
Thank you.
There you go.
Of course, of course, buddy.
That's right.
We're here for our taxes.
See, I respect people.
I see.
I, uh, ignore the past four hours.
I, I, I, I respect them.
Yeah, the last four hours when you cyber bullied of the kid.
I, I did, I did.
I did get a three-day ban.
Oh, like a three-minute ban for saying I was gonna shoot them.
Yeah, when you said you're gonna gun someone down.
Well, to be fair, only a three-minute ban is not that bad.
Yeah, that's true.
Like, I mean, like, I wouldn't.
You changed that person's trajectory.
I was their canon event.
That was you.
Okay, we're not swindling children in Roblox.
The frick is that?
Yeah, we didn't tell them.
That sounds illegal.
Yeah, we didn't tell them to go to our YouTube channel and Twitch channel to give us money.
How could we?
That's so fucked up.
You remember those, like, old YouTubers that would tell people to gamble at CSGO?
You remember?
Oh my god, yes.
Like, dude nods at the stake ads.
Yeah, and then, like, they'll be like, yeah, use my CSGO website to gamble.
Wait, am I good in here?
Yeah, no, yeah.
No, it's got, um, it was a bait.
Oh my god, I lived.
You did it.
Wait, wait, what's that?
There's two!
There was two!
Oh no, I can't rez you again.
Oh no.
It came back.
Jin, stop freaking spamming.
Rez me.
I'm not freaking rezzing you.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
You go hang out with the other Doki.
I'm hiding a pee.
Have a nice freaking piss.
Thank you.
I'll lock in.
This is so freaking upsetting.
Hold on, I'm gonna talk to this Doki.
Hey, let's lock in, okay?
Listen, I need this.
This is all I have.
Oh my god, there's two doors.
It's almost like this game is called doors.
I muted the burp because I swear to god, I think that's why I got a three minute ban.
Wait, did they find the right way?
Why the frick am I getting carried?
This is so freaking upsetting.
That's the wrong way.
Oh, uh, trust, believe in yourself.
Whatever your heart says is the correct door.
You can do it.
Because I'm lagging.
Give me five dollars and I'll pick a door.
Man, really?
You, you choose not over five.
Okay, you don't got five bucks?
Like, come on, you could, you could, you know, like just four dollars.
Four dollars and I'll pick a door.
I'm not, four dollars.
Three dollars, three dollars and I'll pick a door.
Listen.
Yeah, I bet you wish you had three bucks.
They're not speaking to me anymore.
I'm like, I, I, I, I, I think I'm yelling too much.
Is this backwards?
Oh my god, you're still alive?
Yeah, I think my, my guy's going backwards.
Wait, what?
I, I, I, I, I tried to ask them to spend money to, to, to, it didn't work.
This one is, uh, immune, immune to the extortion.
Wait, wait, did you see he going back?
Oh my god, he's always back.
He's back, he's back.
Okay, he found it.
He was lost.
Cyclops.
He was on his own, he was on his own little adventure.
Are you, are you, what happened?
Oh, they're not a guy.
They said they're not a guy.
Sorry, I think it's because your character looks, uh.
What, like, Mocho, what was his name?
The wrestler guy?
About Slim Jims.
Yeah, he's the Slim Jim guy.
Dude, Slim Jims are good.
I've never had a Slim Jim before.
They're like, they're like trashy food that like hits the spot that you regret eating.
Like a hot pocket, you know?
Oh, I see.
Like it's garbage, but like, designated garbage you want.
Oh, it's, yeah, it's Ratty Savage.
Oh, I know who that is.
Why are you letting, why are you letting, uh, this other Jokey be behind you?
Because I am the alpha, and I, I, I, yeah, but alphas, alphas need to let the other, like, uh.
Have you, you hit me as the kind of girl who like, like, out on Omega.
The wolf movie.
Oh, you, the one where the wolf has tits?
Well, yeah, they have like bosoms, and I like had a crush on the white one.
The, the one named Louie.
The one with the big tits?
The like emo one.
No, she, she was like emo shy.
She had like, she had like a face.
Please don't die.
Wait, are you furry?
No, but I'm an ally.
Represent.
You're a furry ally?
Yeah, I'm an ally.
Wait, what was your, no, no.
Okay, so, was she, was Lily your like, furry crush?
You know how like, everyone has one where it's like, you know, there's...
No, if you want to know which one mine was, it's really bad.
Which one was it?
It was Wallace and Gromit, Curse of the Were-Rabbit.
I had a crush on the rabbit.
When I was a kid.
Oh frick.
I swear on my life, it was one of my first crushes.
When it turned into a rabbit, I was like, no.
It's the Were-Rabbit.
The Were-Rabbit.
All right, let's- Rub it some cheese.
And then he turns into the fingers.
Wait, it's this guy.
This guy.
You just don't look it up.
Please don't look it up.
Just don't look it up.
Don't look it up.
It's already too late.
That was the first thing I did.
But like... I watched that movie as a kid and I was like...
Wait a minute.
Hey.
Like, I don't know.
This was... this was...
Chibi's... Chibi's first boyfriend.
Well, no, he blocked... he blocked my number.
What?
The first person Chibi has ever stalked.
Technically, my first like love was Bowser.
Does he count as a furry?
Yes, yes.
I had a crush on him after playing Super Mario Sunshine.
Okay, but are you talking about like the Bara version of Bowser or like regular Bowser?
Any.
Okay, what's your favorite Bowser then?
Probably Super Mario Sunshine because he's like really tall and big.
He's like, you know, he's like giant.
Oh, so like...
The size difference.
I see.
Size queen.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, because you're into the were-ravid too.
And...
I didn't sign up for freaking therapy.
The frick.
Oh, Jesus, I do have a time.
That's bad.
Yeah, you have a time.
Yeah, you do.
Wait, what other ones that...
What other ones that are similar to Bowser and...
What ever happened?
Shut the fr...
Stop!
What other characters?
Guys, what other characters are just like that?
No.
We don't even talk about it.
Yes, we do.
Okay, we're here to...
We're here to like...
King K.
Rool?
Oh, do you like King K.
Oh!
I honestly, I think he's cute, but his personality is too crazy.
He's cute.
I like his little pun.
Yeah.
He's cute.
He's got like a belly button.
Wario or Waluigi?
Yeah, they're cute.
I like them.
How about...
King Dedede?
Oh, no.
Because he's too...
Oh, goodbye Randi.
Goodbye, Randi.
Oh, oh my god.
Please lock in and try every number.
Try one.
Oh, what about Poe from Kung Fu Panda?
I'm not...
I'm not into himbos.
So, no.
They gotta be smart.
Oh, they gotta be smart?
Oh, okay.
What about Bouncer gets an excuse?
Because he's like stupid smart.
You know?
Oh, I mean he's the king.
So, you're in here.
Oh.
Sorry, I got a hard-on thing about Bowser.
Lock in Doki 3.
The blood rushed away.
The blood rushed somewhere.
The blood rushed downwards, right?
Away from the brain.
Try one.
Alright, grab the map.
Alright.
Hey.
In the end...
In the end, I am...
The superior Doki.
I beat your personal best.
You did.
You actually...
I actually bowed down because you did actually do very good at this game.
Especially for this part.
The...
Like I'm actually kinda like picking at my skin right now.
I'm like kinda comparing the voices.
I'm really sad.
It's alright.
It's okay.
You can talk to the...
Hear me out.
If mine...
If you're gonna laugh at me.
My weirdest...
Hear me out.
Yeah.
Cause I'm pretty normal when it comes to...
No the frick you're not.
You...
No you are not normal.
It's the first time they came out when I'm one and you are not.
Okay.
Starscream.
What's Starscream?
From Transformers.
I've never seen Transformers.
Wait you've never seen...
Yo that guy teabagged you.
How do you feel about that?
Smelt like fish.
Starscream?
Oh that's not that bad.
No I like robots too.
Okay look at...
Okay but like...
Okay this...
Let me show you like the hottest Starscream though.
Okay.
Please don't tell me he's showing hole.
No.
This is...
I'll show you the hottest version of him.
Well you did send me like a...
A picture of like an airplane guy with a bot hole.
Are...
Do you have a tiny visit robots?
Okay but look at this guy.
Okay.
This is like...
The hottest version of him.
Okay wait he does have like a nice face.
Wait hold up.
Should I revive?
Wait you have a...
Yes you should revive!
You have a revive!
Sorry I was thinking about sexy robots.
Alright I'm back.
Are you kidding me?
Oh my god but look at...
I swam in front of him.
Okay but look at this though.
Okay in the grabbable waist.
Okay you know...
No Doki I hear you.
I freaking see you.
Yeah yeah yeah.
You hear me.
Yeah.
You understand right?
Okay don't worry chat.
I'll show it to you too.
I love a man built like a Dorito.
You know like big shoulder.
But yeah I get you bro.
Like look at this guys.
Look damn.
She's gooding.
That's my star stream.
That's...
Have you seen like...
I think it's like one of those Disney parks or something.
Where they have like the Transformers like actually do meet and greets and stuff.
Wait what?
Oh yeah yeah with the Megatron.
Those are freaking cool.
And they'll have like...
They'll have like voice...
Like voice actors that will actually like respond to everything you do.
Yeah.
And so...
I love those videos.
They're so freaking cool.
Like guys look at this.
Look at the star screen though.
Like...
I love those artists.
Someone's like...
Someone's like I can take him.
That's a fucking jet plane.
What do you mean?
You can take him?
The jet plane?
What are you freaking Taylor Swift?
What the fuck are you doing?
Someone's like...
I can take him any day.
Like...
Like wait.
Like do you like...
Can he say he's an airplane?
Yeah.
Someone's like in a fight?
Or...
Someone's like in airplane mode.
Oh okay.
In...
Okay.
Starscream...
Plane mode.
Transformers more than meets the eye.
Alright.
Let's see.
Windblade comic.
I can't remember the artist for this though.
This artist is like crazy good.
Are you still alive?
Yes.
But I'm making them do everything.
Nice.
You should just be at the lock then.
While you wait.
Oh you're right.
I should just be like twiddling my thumbs.
Yeah.
Grab the map.
Did you grab the map though?
The...
The combination?
No.
I saw them going for it.
No, no.
You should grab it so...
You should grab it so you can like...
So you'll have the map and see what the code is.
I think they got it already and...
So I'm going to let them prove themselves.
Oh that's true.
Just stay here.
I just don't really want to do it.
You know?
I'm kind of...
You're right.
You're on the higher...
Like hierarchy.
That's right.
Yeah, so you don't have to.
This person, sorry.
Don't worry.
This individual.
I believe...
I don't really believe in them.
But like, you know.
It's good that they're trying.
Okay.
This is what the plane version looks like, guys.
For this com...
For this comic series.
That's a good ass plane.
Uh oh.
Oh my gosh.
Look at that expression though.
Are you seriously a gooning?
I don't want to know what your search history is right now.
That is a cool plane.
Her type is freaking airplane.
Parasocial Andi's in chat.
You will never be enough because you don't freaking fly.
Someone was like...
You don't turn into a plane.
You don't...
I don't think this person knows what to do.
So you're right.
I have to go be the alpha and go get the thing.
It's my duty.
Oh frick.
You just need...
They just need one.
Oh.
You just try...
Just get the map.
Get the map.
And then just try any number.
Because you're just missing one number.
I'll start with one.
So this is your redemption.
This is literally your redemption right here.
I'll start with one.
Okay.
Guys, I don't want to fix star screen.
So it's...
Zero...
Eight zero question mark.
Eight zero...
Eight...
Oh wait no, we also need star.
They don't have star.
Oh, they don't have two?
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
I'll look.
It's eight zero zero eight five.
Mathematically, it could be that one.
Eventually.
Someone out there has got eight zero eight zero eight five.
Please take a screenshot and send it.
You need to see.
Oh, they got it.
They got it.
No, they got the last symbol.
They got the diamond.
Oh, they did.
Okay, they can figure it out.
Okay, I'll make my way back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just slowly make your way back.
Doki should like Chibi because she's kind of built like an airbus.
What the frick does that mean?
Why do I catch trees?
I'm like...
I'm locking the frick in.
All right.
The other guy's locking in.
You gotta head over.
He's unlocking the door.
He unlocked it.
He didn't unlock it, but...
That's okay.
We all start somewhere.
Okay.
Okay, it's on.
Just stand in the corner.
So they can't get you.
It's eight...
Zero.
Oh my god, it's actually eight zero zero.
Oh wait!
Oh my god, it's actually eight zero zero eight!
I'm not even...
There's no way.
No, you're fucking with me.
Hold up!
Eight?
I'm open!
Zero zero eight!
Five!
It's not!
It is boob though!
It is boob!
There's no way!
It actually is boob!
No way!
I can't believe it!
It's...
Oh, what was it?
What was it?
No, we need to know!
They got it!
We need to know!
What was it?
Oh my god, it was boob!
We were so close!
We got boob!
We got boobie!
It's boobie!
Oh my god!
That's so...
We got boobie!
This is actually, like, a moment in this thing.
Yeah, this is a 10 out of 10 game, right there.
Incredible.
By the way, the monster's here, too, so you gotta get into a closet fast.
What?
Get into a room.
Yeah, because I know you don't listen.
Shut the fuck up.
By the way, the other guy died.
You're the last Doki.
The other guy died.
I don't know how the other guy died.
I ain't spending money right now.
This is our last game.
Doki, you got locked in.
We all spent money.
I don't care how much you spam res me.
I'm not resing you.
I'm not... What the frick you mean?
It's time.
You joined our lobby and you're not spending money?
I'm homeless.
What the frick?
What is he?
Oh, oh, oh.
What does he have?
I got $200.
I'll take a flashlight.
I don't think... I don't think it's worth it.
Listen, I just wanna...
Wait, this is it.
This is it.
You can beat my personal best right here.
Easy, watch this.
You're almost there.
You know what?
No, don't.
Don't spend money.
I want her to be there by herself.
I got this.
I'm good with it again.
All you have to do is get to 70.
You're like almost there an inch.
Yeah, but you'll also die too one day.
Actually, I feel like I'm gonna be that person who dies before everyone.
I feel like you'll die before I die.
Hashtag heart condition.
Wait, do you actually?
Yeah.
Wait, why are you playing horror games?
Wait, is that bad?
Yes, if you're... if you have a heart condition.
Wait, really?
Did the doctor never tell you not to play games?
Listen, my doctor thinks I'm a stripper, so...
I don't know.
Wait, how... where did he get that implication?
What did you do?
Did he see you somewhere?
I moved to a new...
Paid me to go away.
I, uh...
Moved to a new area.
Yeah?
And it was the first time I had to have this conversation with...
Sorry.
It was the first time I had like a conversation with...
A fake one.
About... with a doctor.
That was me.
And...
I...
Fumbled so hard.
I didn't know what to say because I didn't want to say I was a streamer because I was ashamed.
So I...
I also...
But I wanted to say like I made content.
But I didn't...
Oh, so you thought you were only fans.
Yeah, I said I...
Well, for some reason I said I'm an adult content creator.
And they...
They left the room.
And then they...
Yeah.
And, um...
It was bad and really embarrassing.
Like, did you just not see your doctor after that?
Like, you couldn't...
Like, you couldn't show your face to the doctor?
Well, no.
Like, I still go back.
And she's like...
She'll be like, so...
Are we active?
And every time I have to go...
No?
So she's just thinking...
Oh, she's like...
Those fetish ones.
You know?
Oh, yeah.
Like I eat like a...
No, like...
Yeah, yeah.
You sit on cake or something.
You know?
Yeah, like I dump like tart on my head.
Yeah, yeah.
Then you like take pictures.
Like show feet or something.
Like close-ups of feet.
And...
It's like...
You know?
That's the adult part.
My doctor thinks I'm a fetish artist.
Yes, I know.
Cause that's...
You keep saying no.
When she asks you if you're active.
Then you're like...
Oh...
She does the other freaky shit.
She does...
And like shit on bananas.
The fetish adult content creators.
Someone's like...
Is that actually a thing?
Cake sitting?
Yeah, it is.
You actually...
People get paid a lot of money to sit on.
Like...
Things.
I don't do that kind of stuff.
But like...
I feel like that's the kind of stuff I would consider.
Like sitting on a cake.
Like how much money?
How much money?
Could I...
Do I have to show my face?
No, no.
It's just your...
Your butt on a cake.
Oh, ten bucks?
Ten dollars?
How many subs is that?
Two.
Alright guys.
You...
No backsies.
Well...
Actually...
Like realistically...
Like to do any...
I don't think I could do any like...
Like smexy content.
Because like...
Okay, but what...
What...
Okay, but what is the...
The sexy part of sitting on a cake?
But like...
Knowing that someone's tickling their pickle to the idea of them being the cake.
Or like that my cheeks being covered in frosting.
I couldn't do it.
It's like when you try to...
Like draw boobs.
And you go...
No.
That's me.
Like I'd be like...
Wait, don't you have a booba toggle?
No.
Oh, then what chibi was that?
I don't have a boob toggle.
So now we're lying.
I actually don't...
Like years ago I spent $5 on a boob asset.
And I used it twice.
I spent $5 on boob.
Wait, that's...
That's like...
Oh my gosh.
That's like double for sitting on cake.
Oh, dude.
I should reinvest.
Yeah, you should reinvest.
I should buy a cake.
Come on.
Oh, frick.
That's the flashy flash.
Yeah.
There it is.
Oh, you're too...
You're too away from beating my record.
This is all I have.
This is all you have.
Oh, I think it's the bait one.
Yeah.
You are sick.
Wait, how did you...
Why would you believe that?
Why?
Because I thought we were friends.
Yeah, but friends lie.
They do?
Oh, frick.
Sorry.
It's freaking spicy in that room.
Okay, looking for a key.
Oh, the key is on the other side.
Key over here?
Yeah.
Listen, I dodged it.
I'm better.
Where the frick is the key?
Where the frick?
Hey!
Because you found the key?
I'm sorry.
Someone said...
Play the sound alert even though they're off.
I don't know the frick it happens.
What are you screaming?
I don't even know what you're screaming at.
Where is the key?
It was right in front of me.
I'm gonna frick at my skin.
Wait, that's 69.
The next door is 69.
Nice.
Oh, oh.
You're 70.
That's my record.
Oh, frick.
Did you get the fucking nice room?
Go!
You get the...
Oh, my God.
Oh, she beat it.
She beat it.
She beat the...
She actually beat my record.
That's right.
Oh.
Well, this game was made for me.
Also wood.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe you didn't get this fucked up hallway shit.
Meow.
It sounds like it.
Cat in the backyard.
Meow.
You did it!
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Look at you go.
This is Rocket League.
Oh, frick.
Oh, mother frick.
Oh, you're by yourself.
You're 20.
It's the one that got you.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
You get that here.
You're so lucky.
Watch out.
They're here to get you.
I'm scared.
He's here to get you.
Oh, frick.
Oh, my God.
He's here.
Stop.
No.
Meow.
Where am I?
I got stuck on a chair.
Famous last words.
I got stuck on a fricking chair.
TV.
We almost did it.
We were like 20 rooms away.
And like, she's just like, have you beaten the game?
I'm like, no.
And you're like, okay.
Like, I've already beaten it.
But I guess we can do.
And we didn't even get close.
We didn't get to chapter one.
We got 80.
We got 80 rooms.
That's not bad, though.
That's pretty bad.
I mean, that's pretty good.
That's pretty good.
Yo!
Yay!
Alright, we are in the lobby.
Where are you?
In the lobby, okay.
You can say goodbye to the...
We'll say goodbye.
Let's go to the...
Yeah, let's go to the fireplace.
Fireplace, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's get in our chair.
The doki's on the chair.
Wait, you're waiting.
Come here, doki's.
Come here.
Approach us.
Come here, doki's.
If you're on... Welcome to our meet and greet.
The doki greet.
Get everybody here for our meet and greet.
Alright guys, welcome.
Welcome, welcome.
No, it's like $10.
Yeah, this will be $10 per case sitting.
$10 per second.
Oh, that's good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry.
I'm the business one of the cheap, the doki squad.
Out of the doki's, I'm the business one.
Chibi, what are you then, Chibi?
I'm the one that eats salt land.
The real, the real meet and greet.
I eat cold chips.
That's our special doki.
Don't get close to her.
No, I bite.
GG's.
This is so much fun.
Yeah, it was fun.
I'm glad to...
Thank you so much.
Yeah, it was fun.
Yeah, it took us so long to organize this collab.
I was still in my chat because like, I would keep like...
You were so sweet and reaching out.
And I'd be like, oh my god, I'm so excited.
But then I'd get really shy.
And then I'm like, I'll just respond tomorrow when I'm less nervous.
And then two weeks go by.
And I'm like, oh frick, now I can't respond.
Because it'd be weird.
And then I would message you.
I was like, hey, yeah.
I was wondering if you still want to do this collab.
And I was like, you know, add me on Discord.
And then like months passed.
And I was like, okay.
I would get so shy that I would be like, nah, I'll just push it off.
And then we finally got each other.
After like, what?
Like three to four months.
We finally got our Discord's added.
I'm not glazing.
I'm not sucking up.
But you're just cool.
And like, I need to go under the slide at recess.
Like, you're the kid with like Bakugans, bro.
Yeah, you're the kid with the fake Pokemon cards that your grandparents bought.
That my step-dad got me.
They're always sticky.
Always eating them.
I'm using them to pick food out of my teeth.
You're like, hey guys, I also have the Pokemon cards.
Look at that.
Look at what my dad got me.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
And then, but yeah, it was great.
I'm happy we got to finally play.
The Toki's got to finally do a collab together.
It was really fun.
That was a lot of fun.
Yeah.
My kid really loves you.
So they were very excited.
Yeah.
Very, yeah.
My dad.
Yeah, my child.
My...
I finally have a dad.
This is wonderful.
Yeah.
Don't worry.
I'll be back.
I just need to get milk real quick.
Okay, don't worry.
I'll wait by the door.
Yeah, yeah.
Just wait by the door, child.
I'll be...
I just gotta grab some milk real quick.
And then we'll definitely...
Don't forget the cigarettes.
Yeah.
We'll definitely collab again, guys.
This is our last collab ever.
The last collab that ever happened.
And then Dad never came back.
Yeah, you've never seen it again.
This is our graduation trip.
Yeah.
Like, I...
We'll bump into each other and like on the street and then I'll look away.
I'll...
Like, we're shopping at Walmart, we both reach for the raisin brand, and you just walk away.
And you're like, Dad?
And then I just walk away.
I'll find you in the milk aisle.
Yeah, Dad, Dad, it's been ten years.
Did you get the milk, Dad?
This is so real.
But it's been fun, G.V.
I had a great time.
I hope we do collab again.
Listen, that's up to you if you get the fucking milk.
If I come back with milk, whenever I come back from milk, we'll do another collab.
Alright, I'll see you in ten years.
Yeah, I'll catch you in ten years.
Oh, you need butter.
Yeah, I'll be like, son, I need to borrow...
I need five dollars.
I need to borrow a thousand dollars real quick, son.
Why did you invest in hot coins?
I invested in this new cryptocurrency.
Do you know about cryptocurrency?
Oh, wait, but do you know anything?
Oh, you heard about those new cool things called NFTs?
They're non-refund...
Oh, the lucky profile figures.
Yeah, they're...
What was it called?
The non-refundable...
Like, tokens or something?
I don't know.
Oh, my God, son.
I heard so much about these NFTs.
Our next collab, guys...
I'm announcing it now.
I know you didn't want to say anything.
Yeah.
But our next collab, we are starting a cryptocurrency.
And we're going to pull the rug to everything.
So, you guys are going to be there.
Show for five dollars.
It's going to be called...
Not a rug pull.
Yeah, not a hashtag not a rug pull.
Get that trending.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Invest, invest, invest.
But Gigi's TV.
Yes, Gigi, Gigi.
That was a really fun.
Um, I definitely hope we do something like this again when I come back from...
With milk.
A little bit...
A big if.
Yeah, yeah, if...
If I come back...
But yeah, I hope you have a great time with your chat later on.
I'm not sure if y'all will keep streaming, but...
I'm probably going to go make dinner.
So...
Oh, okay, yeah.
Are you going to keep streaming?
Nah, I'm going to head off too.
I'm going to get food as well.
I have a nice...
Oh, you're going to get some milk and...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Remember, that's why I said go milk.
You know?
Oh, I got some food.
Oh, because you're going to make dinner.
Yeah, I'm going to make dinner for us.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, of course, for my child.
It's the best day in my life.
Yeah, don't worry.
Just wait at the door and I'll be there.
Okay, I'll wait at the door.
I won't eat.
I'll wait for you.
Yeah, yeah, just wait there.
Don't worry.
Don't have to get any food.
Yay.
I got out of the air.
And then it's like, she was never seen again.
You're like, Dad?
I'm sorry.
I forgot my watch.
Oh, frick.
I thought you'd be dead by now.
I forgot my book in the car.
I'm sorry.
I forgot my watch.
That was bye.
Forgot my keys in the car.
I'll be right back.
Yeah, I'll be right back.
Don't worry.
I'll be back.
Just wait here.
Okay, Father.
But it was fun, Chibi.
It was fun.
I hope you have a good dinner.
I'm glad I taught you about collab rooms.
I'm excited, dude.
I can't believe I can grab people.
You can also put props on them, too.
Yeah.
Okay, now she has ideas.
I waited until the end of the stream to tell her that.
Because I knew she was going to take advantage of her new knowledge.
I... I knew she was going to take advantage of it.
But you can play... Why is it so tiny?
Sorry.
I don't know.
That's a fun tip to you.
Um, it's above average.
Wait, why is it upside down now?
What the more?
Why is it big?
What is happening?
I'm trying to make you... Okay, well, I guess this is how it works, then.
It's above average.
I'm sad.
What the fuck are you doing?
How do I take item?
Yeah.
I'm trying to make you spin it glizzy, but it's consuming you.
I don't know.
It's consuming you.
How do I get... It's stuck on you.
I can't get it off.
What did you do?
That's just me now.
Okay, well... Well, look at you go.
This is supposed to be on your chcevel.
Look at you go!
Wait, I can't get it off.
What the fuck?
I can't get it off.
Why is it...
Wait, I see it!
I see it!
Oh my god!
It's home!
Okay, I can move it!
I can move it!
Okay.
Get it off minutes!
Get it off!
That's right.
It's on you now.
You think you're safe.
You think you're safe from the glizzies of it.
Yoink.
I'm taking it.
Gold!
We stopped!
Why is there so many glizzies?
What are you doing?
Don't worry.
It took up my whole screen.
What the frick did you do?
More glizzies.
Come on, we did more.
Alright.
Here's my child and her glizzies.
Here's my child trying to do a glizzie right now.
We did more.
Yeah.
You're like pinned on me.
Wait, I can pin you on me.
I... Wait!
Wait, really?
Yeah!
Oh my god!
The frickin' hotdog is back!
Wait, wait.
You can pin... I can pin yourself... Pin you on me.
There you go.
You're like dancing on my head.
No!
Look at you.
How will I get rid of this giant hot dog?
I don't think... No, you keep putting... I'm throwing them away.
I'm throwing these glizzies away.
I look like I'm infected.
Yeah, by the glizzy pox.
Look, I'm not... Dude, I'm holding you.
I'm holding you like a subway foot long.
You're like, um... You're just on my head.
I went fishing today.
Look at that cat.
Why is this... We have a minion on our... Look at that cat.
I caught me a good one.
You're good now, brother.
Oh my god.
You go, child.
Dude, I love that you have crocs.
Oh yeah, you love it?
Yeah, it's on attack mode.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it's on attack... I'm always on attack mode.
Alright, anyway.
That's... As much as your... The time's up.
Your mom paid this...
Did my make-a-wish?
Yeah.
Yeah, your mom paid...
Sorry.
Your mom only paid for this much amount of time for me to hang out with you.
I know.
It's okay.
I understand.
You got... I know.
I know.
It's okay.
You understand, right?
You understand the drill.
I've seen 10 years.
Yeah, I know.
My mom had to pay for my dad to hang out with me.
Yeah, yeah.
She was like... He needed cigarette money.
She told him... She's threatening him.
She's threatening me.
Okay.
But... Goodbye, my child.
Goodbye, dad.
I'll see you soon.
Yeah, I'll see you soon.
Wait at the door for me, okay?
Okay.
Alright.
I'll wait.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye, Chibi.
Alright, that was good.
That was a really fun stream with Chibi.
I'm glad we were able to finally do our collab together.
Um...
Like I said, this has been, like, planned for...
Like, we've been trying to collab with each other for, like, the longest time.
Because, obviously, like, you know, Chibi with Chibi.
That, like, Doki with Doki.
It makes so much more sense...
So much sense to do a collab together.
So, I'm really happy.
And it was really fun.
I had a lot of fun.
I'm glad her mom paid.
I'm glad her mom bought this cameo.
But, um...
I'm gonna head off now, guys.
I hope you guys had a fun time hanging out with us.
Um...
No stream...
Oh, wait.
Yes.
Yes stream on tomorrow.
I'll be playing two hours of Mecha Break at 12.30 p.m.
Um...
Uh...
For a sponsor.
So, tomorrow's a sponsor stream for Mecha Break.
Uh...
Monday, there's no stream, though.
Monday, there's no stream.
Uh...
But I will be streaming tomorrow.
Um...
Anyway, guys.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you...
Stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Because...
You deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
I hope you guys enjoyed the Doki Doki stream.
Bye, guys.
Bye.